Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 11. Ausgabe dieser Serie. Und heute wird es eine diffuse Reise in dein Themenfeld, was mir ein bisschen schwerfällt, von Vornherein schon mit einem einzigen Schlagwort zu erschlagen. Wir wollen ein wenig reden über so das Leben und Lernen vor allem und das Erreichen von Zielen in der digitalen Ära, der von Digitaltechnologie, Informationstechnologie geprägten Zeit. Und natürlich auch, was das so für die Wissenschaft zu bedeuten hat. Und dazu begrüße ich Gunter Dück, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Sie sind ja schon so einiges gewesen in Ihrem Leben. Wissenschaftler, Manager und mittlerweile vor allem auch Vortragender, kann man das so sagen? Ist das ein Beruf?
Ich erkläre meine Bücher.
Ahja okay, also Autor.
Ja.
Okay. Aber wie fing es denn an so mit dem Lebenslauf? Also wann kam denn das erste Mal so eigentlich die Fragestellung der Lebensplanung so wirklich auf den Tisch?
Ja ich komme vom Bauernhof.
Wo?
Großhimstedt???, das ist im Herzen Niedersachsens, also bei Hildesheim irgendwo da bisschen zu Braunschweig rüber. 400 Einwohner oder 479 irgendwo. Und gefühlt, ich glaube, ich war der erste oder so, der Abitur gemacht hat, der es versucht hat. Also die Leute haben dann in meiner Straße gestanden und gesagt, das schaffst du nicht. Weil man immer schon um 6 Uhr raus musste.
Ja, und 14:30 Uhr kam man zurück. Also wir hatten, ich glaube, es haben drei oder vier gleichzeitig dann mal probiert in dem Jahrgang und ich bin dann übergeblieben. Also die haben dann gleich den Absprung gemacht nach der 5. oder 6. Klasse. Und ich habe es dann wirklich durchgezogen bis zum Abitur. Das war schon ganz gut.
Der erste in der Gemeinde?
Und warum?
Weil mein Vater ziemlich viele Brüder hatte. Das sind so Mennoniten???, die haben unendlich viele Kinder. Und da erbt der jüngste Sohn, weil der am längsten da ist und die Eltern noch pflegen kann, den ganzen Hof und die anderen nichts. Und weil der Hof – da hat man gesagt, pass auf, ich kann euch nichts geben, also die älteren, ihr macht alle Abitur, dann könnt ihr einen vernünftigen Beruf haben. Und das hat die ganze Großfamilie da so gemacht. Also es war völlig klar, dass ich jetzt auch Abitur machen muss.
Wie viele andere Kinder gab es denn noch?
Mein Vater hat 6 Brüder und eine Schwester. Und mein Großvater ist Kind 20 von 24. Aber ich habe nur eine Schwester.
Okay.
Es war aber klar, dass wir beide dann Abitur machen. Wir sind Flüchtlinge. Mein Vater hatte den Hof dann, er hat ein bisschen eingeheiratet in eine Pacht und es war klar, dass man die nicht weiterführen kann. Also Bauer konnte ich gar nicht werden. Wollte ich auch nicht. Und da war ich immer gut in Mathe und dann habe ich das studiert.
Ich wollte eigentlich lieber Dichter werden, aber das kriege ich ja noch hin. Oder habe ich so halbwegs hingekriegt.
Also war jetzt schon das Studium sozusagen die herausragende Leistung oder schon das Erreichen des Abiturs?
Das war dann klar, dass ich dann Mathe studiere.
Nein, ich meine jetzt innerhalb dieser Gemeinde, weil alle anderen da gescheitert sind. Oder das überhaupt gar nicht im Prinzip vorgestellt haben.
Nein später haben viele das versucht. Also das ist dann auch so normal geworden. Nur mal geguckt so, wie die ersten sich da so tun. Und in Kleinhimmstedt hat auch Ingelore hat auch Abitur geschafft. Also dann haben wir so als erste Protagonisten, sind dann viele hinterher gekommen und haben das dann auch gemacht. Also da änderte sich einfach so ein bisschen die Gesellschaft. Und dann ist man natürlich so aus dem Dorf raus. Man muss dann irgendwo in Göttingen studieren, fanden alle. Also weil das die beste Uni war. Also man kann natürlich auch Braunschweig und Hannover irgendwas machen. Aber so Göttingen hatte eben diesen absoluten Weltruf als Eliteuniversität. Und dann bin ich halt als Student nach Göttingen.
Dann kam wieder so die erste Stunde, also die erste …
In welchem Jahr sind wir jetzt?
71.
Ich habe dann – der Assistent der ersten Stunde hat uns dann erklärt, ja wir haben ja heute einen starken Jahrgang diesmal, 220 Leute. Anfänger in Mathematik. Und er freut sich, dass wir alle da sind und wir sollen uns aber keine Illusionen machen, ungefähr 20 von uns werden ein Diplom machen und ein paar, die es nur so halb bringen, die können ja noch Lehrer werden. Also so der Output wird 35 sein schätzt er. Und so ist das dann auch gekommen.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Weil?
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich habe eine Erklärung, also ich habe ja das alles durchgemacht, bin dann später selber Assistent geworden, Professor geworden in Mathematik. Habe mich um das Weitergeben von Mathematik gekümmert. Mein Sohn ist durch irgend ja halbwegs Zufall, hat er auch Mathe angefangen zu studieren in Heidelberg. Das ist ja auch eine Eliteuni, also sehr sehr schwer da alles. Und hat jetzt auch gerade den Doktor super super super bestanden. Also ich habe praktisch nochmal das alles mitgemacht. Und ich denke, dass die Mathematik es irgendwie unnötig schwer macht, da reinzukommen. Also es kann in anderen Fächern auch sein, also man lernt gar nicht so viel Wissen oder Erkenntnis, sondern man lernt den Formalismus. Also praktisch eigentlich die Konventionen, also wie man schließt, wann was ein Beweis ist, wie man den führt, welche Denktricks man dazu hat, dass man langsam so einen Baukasten hat von bestimmten Methoden oder so.
Die Erkenntnisse als solche sind gar nicht so umwerfend schwer.
Die rein mathematischen Erkenntnisse.
Ja. Und man verliert den Blick irgendwie. Also der Formalismus vernebelt den Blick so sehr, dass man irgendwie denkt, man hat Probleme es zu verstehen, aber man kommt mit den Methoden irgendwie nicht klar.
Das heißt Mathematik lernen ist eher das Rüstzeug, Mathematik zu beschreiben, als selber zu rechnen.
Man muss seinen Kopf trainieren. Diesen ganzen Formalismus, diesen wissenschaftlichen Kram da in sich reinzukriegen, dass man irgendwie weiß, wie die Wissenschaft denkt und dann kann man natürlich den Stoff dann auch relativ leicht aufsaugen, das ist nicht der Punkt. Also ich erinnere mich an einen so nach Woche 4 oder 6, da sagt mein Sohn, du Papa ich kann das nicht. Dann sage ich, pass mal auf, die Aufgabe ist einfach doof. Die verlangt keinen intellektuellen Kontent, du sollst einfach nur da so deine Kästchen da runter rechnen. Das ist so einfach Fingerübung, das hat gar nichts mit Erkenntnis zu tun. Und da hat er mich fast umgehauen vor Zorn. Und hat halt gesagt, er kriegt es nicht hin und da kommt einer so an und sagt, da muss man nichts verstehen, rechne einfach ein bisschen.
Und dann ist er ja später jetzt Assistent geworden und dann kam er eines Tages nach Hause und hat gesagt, er musste so an mich denken, wie er mich damals würgen wollte und er hat jetzt gerade einen Studenten im ersten Semester gehabt und er kommt mit so einer Babyaufgabe nicht klar. Und da hat er eben gesagt, guck mal, da musst du nichts erkennen, du musst einfach nur so locker runter. Da wollte der den erwürgen und hat bei sich so... das ist der Punkt. Also praktisch man muss so ein Fach vielleicht 1-2-3 Semester aushalten und dann hat sich das gesetzt und der Pulverdampf verzieht und dann ist es relativ einfach. Und die meisten Leute werden dadurch abgeschreckt. Ich würde das anders machen. Aber ich habe das mal den Mathematikern vorgeschlagen, ich war ja auch im Präsidium der Deutschen Mathematikervereinigung 8 Jahre. Ich würde einfach mal so eine Anfängervorlesung wegnehmen und dafür eine so Übersichtsvorlesung machen, was eigentlich die Erkenntnisse der Mathematik sind. Also ohne den Formalismus.
Also dass man eine Woche erklärt, was Funktionentheorie ist, eine Woche was Algebra, was Statistik, Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie und Zahlentheorie und so weiter halt Topologie ist. So würde ich auch in Wirtschaft machen. Einfach einen Rundumkurs, was ist Marketing, was ist Bankbetriebslehre, was ist Finanzmarkt. Damit man überhaupt mal weiß, wo man hin will. Und dass man nicht gleich so mit Definitionen vollgepfropft wird, die sehr formal sind und die einen eigentlich abhalten. Und dieses Problem sehe ich eigentlich in vielen Studiengängen. Also ich kenne jetzt praktisch nur Ingenieur, BWL habe ich selber auch mal versucht, also in Göttingen zu studieren. Man wird einfach vollgepumpt mit Formalismus, also mit der wissenschaftlichen Sprache, ohne zu wissen, was man eigentlich da macht.
Und warum.
Ja dann sagen sie, guck mal, warte erst mal, nach dem Vordiplom kommt dann der Stoff echt.
Und vorher ist mehr so Training.
Mehr so Training in einfach.
So bisschen wie beim Fußball. Erstmal 20 mal ums Stadion rum, um so die Grundfestigkeit zu haben und dann kann man sich auch um das Spielerische kümmern.
Nein, es kann ja auch sein, ist auch so in der Kampfsportart, dass man einfach nur so lernt, den rechten Fuß schnell vorsetzen, dann den linken Fuß und dann macht man das ein paar Jahre und irgendwann fängt man an, zu kämpfen. Dann wäre es aber besser, man wüsste das. Also ich meine, bei Sport ist es so, dass man ja eigentlich nicht nur Fußball lernt, sondern gleichzeitig die WM guckt. Also man sieht auch gleich sozusagen die Meisterschaft. Und wenn ich anfange, Bilder zu malen, kann ich ja in ein Museum gehen. In den Wissenschaften ist das oft sehr schwierig. Also ich kann, wenn ich jetzt Linguist werde oder so, dann kann ich mir einen Linguisten nicht angucken.
Mathe-WM gibt es auch nicht.
Ein Starmathematiker hilft nicht anzugucken, das ist dann so ein blasser, schwacher, introvertierter Mensch und der hat gerade irgendeine Vermutung gelöst. Und dann sagen Sie, der ist jetzt berühmt. Aber ich kann wenig angucken. Und ich finde, wir brauchen da mehr Beispiele, also so was zu sehen. Und da könnte, wenn wir noch heute dazu kommen, das Internet ja eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Also dass man was zum Anfassen hat. Also ich meine, jetzt man kann auch Schachspielen lernen, indem man einfach lernt lange, wie der Springer zieht, wie der Läufer zieht und welche strategischen Sachen und wann eine Bauernkette geschlossen, offen gehalten werden muss, wann man Linien öffnet. Man lernt, man lernt, man lernt. Also ich lerne zum Beispiel am besten, in dem ich einfach ein Buch nehme Borsi Spaski??? gegen Fischer und dann spiele ich die Dinger nach.
Also jetzt einfach nur die Züge ohne Interpretation.
Ja und dann steht, ja auch mit Interpretation. Da guck mal, das ist toll, das wird er so machen können und da gibt es diese und dann überlegt man sozusagen alle Varianten und sagt, wow ist das klug. Und dann weiß man aber, wo die Latte hängt. Also ich kann mir in vielen Dingen, also bei Chirurgen und so was, kann ich mir noch angucken, was das ist und in manchen eben nicht. Und das fand ich immer so ein bisschen bedrückend.
Jetzt speziell bei der Mathematik?
Bei Mathematik, bei Wirtschaft ist es auch ein bisschen. Das muss man mal gemacht haben. Also da wird immer gesagt, was sind die Einnahmen, was sind Kosten, was ist Umsatz. Und dann versucht man, den Leuten das so beizubringen, so als gelernte Definition. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Einnahmen und Umsatz. Also was ist steuerfrei, was ist so, was ist Deckungsbeitrag I und II und dann lernen die Leute das. Und ich selber kann das eigentlich nur lernen, Sie könnten mich jetzt so mal drei Tage so einen Betrieb führen lassen, dann merke ich es ja. Dann kann man das mit Dingen verbinden. Und ich finde es immer sehr theoretisch an der Uni.
Also ich denke so, wenn man sich etwas nähert, auch schnell überhaupt erst mal zu wissen, wo man sich befindet. So wo man sich da selber einsortieren kann. Das ist wichtig. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe sagen Sie, davon gibt es zu wenig. Oder gab es zumindest 1971 zu wenig. Vermutlich auch noch ein paar Jahre später.
Ja es ist wahrscheinlich sauschwierig. Ich habe das mal jetzt so gepredigt, also kann mal einer fünf Stunden Algebra erklären, also worum es eigentlich geht. Das könnte ich nicht. Also ich meine ich habe einen Übungsschein für Algebra, aber dazu gehört dann so eine einsteinartige Lichterscheinung, die wirklich da so 20 Jahre drauf geforscht hat und kann dann einen Überblick geben. Das gehört zu den größten Künsten so einer Wissenschaft, einmal über so ein ganzes Feld zu sagen, was die Probleme sind seit Pythagoras, wie sich das entwickelt hat, bisschen geschichtlich einordnen, was sind die Probleme, wo kommen die her, wo wird jetzt Algebra benutzt, also bei Kodierungstheorie zum Beispiel. Jetzt im Internet auch. Also bei den Prüfziffern und so, die ja da eine Rolle spielen und ??? waren.
Da sind so schwache Algebrastrukturen drin, die kann man sehr sehr tiefsinnig machen. Und einer, der jetzt über diese ganze Sache fantastisch gut Bescheid weiß, den gibt es nicht so oft. Das heißt man kann im Grunde nicht in der Uni erwarten, dass da einer aufkreuzt und das richtig gut kann. Also ich glaube nicht, dass jede Uni so gut besetzt ist, dass sie alle Gebiete mal so richtig so eine wunderschöne 1-Wochen-Vorlesung halten kann. Glaube ich nicht.
Es sei denn, man bildet Leute speziell darin aus?
Naja es gibt einen weltweit für das Internet, das gibt es. Und da könnte man jetzt ganz andere Denkweisen geben, wie man Leuten das klarmacht. Also ich kann ja ein paar Superstars finden, aber nicht in jeder Uni. Also wenn ich jetzt die Bedingungen nicht mehr habe, dass die jetzt an der Kreidetafel neben mir sein müssen, dann kann ich ja sehr viel mehr tun.
Blendet man sich einfach das passende Hologramm ein sozusagen.
Ja. Also ich meine deswegen sagt man ja auch, da gibt es diese MassiveOnlineCourses, man sieht, wenn jetzt so ein begnadeter Mensch wirklich über selbstfahrende Autos reden kann, dann kommen 100.000 Leute. Und dann sagen die Leute, nehmen wir irgendeinen anderen Professor, der redet jetzt auch mal über weiß ich Wasserheide??? oder so und dann kommen aber nur 5. Den Punkt, den ich machen will, es gibt so irgendwie begnadeter Menschen, und die muss man vielleicht so handverlesen sammeln oder vielleicht mit 1 Million Jahresgehalt einfangen und einfach mal richtig schöne Dinge von sich geben, das würde dann der ganzen Menschheit weiterhelfen.
Klingt für mich so ein bisschen nach TED-Talks.
Ja zum Beispiel.
Die haben ja so ein bisschen diese Rolle aufgenommen. So Leute, die was zu erzählen haben, fassen so in 10 Minuten mal die Sache von oben sozusagen zusammen und das findet ja durchaus auch große Nachfrage.
Ja da war ich jetzt auch 3-4 mal. Da hat man das Gefühl, da darf ich ja erzählen, was ich will so ein bisschen. Also mehr oder weniger. Also das ist nicht, dass das Thema vorgeschrieben ist, sondern ich rede einfach über das, wo ich meine erleuchtend drüber reden zu können. Da kommt auch was richtig gutes dabei raus.
Das ist eh sinnvoll, wenn die Leute mal über das reden würden, wovon sie wirklich was verstehen.
Ja und jetzt müsste man einfach auch mal sozusagen die Fachgebiete der Welt nehmen und dann irgendwie Leute finden, die erleuchtend gut über genau dieses reden können. Ist aber nicht einfach.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, in dem Moment, wo man jetzt in die Wissenschaft, ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt die Betrachtung von Algebra sich jetzt irgendwie mit der Mode ändern würde.
Nein.
Ich meine, das was man in den 80ern oder 90ern über Algebra so insgesamt hätte erzählen können, das ist heutzutage nicht nennenswert anders. Dann gibt es vielleicht noch ein paar...
Nein ich habe gerade gesagt, das braucht man jetzt in Kodierungstheorie. Also es hat überraschende Wendungen gegeben und auch Anwendungen. Also man könnte es jetzt ergänzen.
Ja gut ergänzen, aber das bis dahin...
Sozusagen es wird das, was bis dahin ist ist nicht falsch.
Genau so und das müsste sich ja eigentlich zusammentragen lassen und zweiter Gedanke, wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll auch die Ausbildung der Professoren oder sonstigen Lehrkörper dementsprechend auch ???
Ja gut, die findet ja nicht statt. Also man habilitiert einfach. Also noch nicht mal das muss man heute. Also heute muss man einfach viele Publikationen haben, und kann dann Professor werden. Also früher war das irgendwie so ein formaler Akt, also Habilitation, dann war man professorabel und es wurde aber eigentlich nicht geguckt, ob man irgendwie Vorlesungen machen könnte. Also mir hat man damals sogar eher abgeraten, Vorlesungen vor der Habilitation zu machen, weil ich dann Zeit verliere, um Papers zu machen. Ich habe gesagt, wenn ich den Beruf später habe, sollte ich vielleicht mal was mit Studenten zusammen machen. Das war auch so, also ich könnte das gar nicht. Es war so, dass ich nicht viel mehr als 4-6 Stunden konzentriert forschen könnte. Also dass man sich so reindenken kann in was. Da muss man irgendwie doch mal zwischendurch immer Kaffee trinken und dann kann man auch eine Vorlesung halten, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Also ich habe das irgendwie gar nicht als lästige Pflicht empfunden. Ich habe dann probiert, Leute irgendwie dafür zu interessieren und auch Vorlesungen gut zu halten. Ich habe dann auch immer, ich glaube ich habe in der Rangliste der besten Vorlesungen immer nach dem Rektor Grothemeier??? auf Platz 2 so gefühlt 3.
Auf Basis welcher Bewertung?
Studenten. Die haben dann abgestimmt, der Rektor konnte, der Herr Grothemeier??? der ist schon gestorben, der konnte so, der war einer dieser erleuchtenden Menschen, die so sagen konnten. Und Friedrich Gauß und ich in Göttingen haben da mal drüber geguckt, und dann haben wir das gesehen. Guck mal am Himmel. Dann haben wir mal Coschi??? angerufen in Paris oder so. Der konnte das wirklich so erleuchtend erklären, das war toll. Also das gab es, da sind alle hingepilgert auch. Weil auch deshalb, weil er harmlose Noten gegeben hat, aber er hat einfach auch tolle Vorlesungen gemacht.
Er wusste schon, wie er sich alle zu eigen macht. Ja also gute Wissensvermittlung ohne Frage ist natürlich eine Kunst.
Das lernt man halt nicht.
Kann man oder nicht.
Ja ich kann einfach jetzt Mathematik studieren und normal immer nur publizieren, ohne jemals einen Studenten gesehen zu haben. Dann werde ich Professor aufgrund der Publikationen und dann muss ich denen das halt beibringen und da habe ich aber weder eine Ahnung, noch wahrscheinlich Lust dazu. Also wer bis dahin noch keine Lust hatte, der kriegt sie ja auch nicht mehr. Und das geht einfach nicht. Da wird lange diskutiert drüber. Es gibt ab und zu mal so ketzerische Bemerkungen, dass man so was wie Lehrprofessoren haben könnte, also die nur lehren und gar nicht forschen. Da gibt es irgendwie dann Ärger, weil die dann vielleicht schlechter bezahlt werden müssen, weil die Forscher sich wichtiger fühlen.
Dann kann man natürlich wieder sagen, zum Stechen, hilft nichts. Die humboldtschen Ideale sagen, dass der Lehrer, der Professor lehrt, da ist von Forschung gar nicht die Rede, also kann man nachgucken, was humboldtsche Bildung ist oder was Universitas ist. Universitas kommt von so was wie, Gemeinschaft der Professoren mit den Lehrenden und die sollen denen das beibringen. Man hat dann gesagt irgendwann nach einer gewissen Zeit, es wäre ja gar nicht so schlecht, wenn die auch ein bisschen forschen, damit die noch wissen, wo Highend ist, also die nicht irgendwie durchschnittlichen Kram erklären auf der Hochschule, sondern irgendwie wissen, wo die Exzellenzlinie ist. Und da wäre es gar nicht so schlecht, dass sie auch ein bisschen zur Forschung beitragen. Aber das mit dem Forschen ist neu. Und jetzt ist das völlig umgeschlagen. Also die Idee früher mal bei den Universitäten war, dass man eigentlich lehrt und meinetwegen forscht. Das ist geduldet worden. Und jetzt ist es so, dass man im Grunde karrieremäßig nur noch irgendwas wert ist, wenn man forscht und das mit dem Lehren, ja gut das muss man dann machen.
Also man macht es gerade so gut, dass dann die Bewertungen im Spiegel oder so ganz gut sind. Aber es ist kein richtiger Ehrgeiz dabei. Jetzt werden ganz viele wieder protestieren, ich habe aber Ehrgeiz. Das mag ich nicht. Also ich kriege immer Leserbriefe, aber meine Schule macht das und ich bin immer bemüht. War ich ja auch. Das Problem ist, das reicht nicht, wenn 10 oder 20% das richtig machen, sondern das muss eine wirkliche Breitenbewegung werden. Und bei diesen ganzen Reformen, wenn ich jetzt immer schimpfe, ich will ein neues Bildungssystem, dann kommen immer welche, die sind richtig gut. Meinetwegen, was immer ich kritisiere, gibt es dann doch Gegenbeispiele und die Gegenbeispiele plustern sich auf und sagen, aber bei mir ist es gut, in meiner Schule ist es gut, in meiner Uni ist es gut. Und die diskreditieren dann sozusagen die Kritik am ganzen System. Weil sie sagen, guck ich bin ein Leuchtturm hier.
Und dann sage ich, pass mal auf, wenn ihr ein Leuchtturm seid, dann macht doch mit, kritisiert das System und sagt, macht so wie ich oder so, aber sagt nicht, das System ist gar nicht so schlecht, wie der Dück das macht. Ja weil wenn sozusagen die 5-10% über Kritik erhabenen immer sagen, das stimmt gar nicht, dann ist es immer wieder abgewendet und man kommt irgendwie zu keinem guten Ergebnis.
Sie waren dann glaube ich in Bielefeld mit der Professur, dann beauftragt. Wie viel Forschung war denn da?
Das war dann eine super Universität. Also die ist neu gegründet, 74. Da bin ich als erster, also ich bin in einen Neubau eingezogen als Assistent. Also ich hatte da gerade mein Diplom fertig.
In so ein schönes graues 70er Jahre Haus.
Ja so ein ganz großes Teil. 500 Meter lang oder so.
Ein Traum.
Und war ganz praktisch. Also unten waren alle Ladengeschäfte und Hörsäle. Im ersten Stock war die Bibliothek immer zu. Also wenn man sich das wie ein Kreis, so ein langes Stadion vorstellt, da waren quasi über dem Hörsaal für, weiß ich, Romanistik ist die Bibliothek für Romanistik. In der zweiten Etage sind die Seminarräume. In der dritten Etage die Verwaltung und 4,5-9,10 die Professoren und Lehrkräfte. Und dann war das alles so relativ eng zusammen. Also die Fakultäten waren dann so sozusagen vertikal geordnet und dann so rundrum. War nicht schlecht. Die Idee war, dass man damals – ich weiß die genauen Zahlen nicht mehr – so jedes 5. oder 6. Semester forschungsfrei hatte.
Ja. Das gibt es ja immer noch, das Forschungssemester.
In Bielefeld nicht.
Ach so nicht?
Nein, damals konnte man einfach sagen, jetzt habe ich fünf Semester Lehre gemacht, ich armes Schwein so ungefähr und jetzt muss ich mal ein Semester nur forschen und das war damals so eine Ausnahmegenehmigung, das kriegte man sonst an den Unis nicht. Man konnte das beantragen. Aber da war das sozusagen das Recht, ab und zu einfach so ein Turnus, dann fällt das weg. Und wegen dieses Goodies hat man sehr sehr gute Professoren gekriegt. Also da konnte man, Bielefeld konnte sich dann wohl eine Zeit lang sich die aussuchen. Deswegen war die hoch gut besetzt. Natürlich haben sie das dann wieder vergessen vom Ministerium. Haben die gesagt, macht doch immer Lehre, weil die Studentenzahlen stark gestiegen sind und dann ist dieser Anfangsvorteil wieder weg.
Das heißt das System lenkt an der Stelle ja dann doch wiederum den Schwerpunkt auf die Lehre und nicht so sehr auf die Forschung. Obwohl eigentlich jetzt karrieremäßig ein Wissenschaftler heutzutage mit Papers und Forschungsergebnissen brillieren muss.
Ja muss, Lehre wird immer weggemacht. Also die Lehre hat irgendwo so ein Schattendasein bei der ganzen Sache. Also auch in Bielefeld sowieso, weil ja dann die brillanten Forscher dahingegangen sind, weil sie dann ab und zu mal ein Semester gar nichts mit Lehre zu tun haben. Und das fanden sie total gut.
Und ist das egal oder ist das doof?
Also ich habe das gern gemacht.
Weil ich meine, das ist egal, welchen Stellenwert man ihm jetzt beimisst oder ich meine Studenten sehen das sicherlich anders.
Ich habe das, ich bin auch deswegen ganz gern zu IBM gegangen. Ich war zum Vorstellungsgespräch im Wissenschaftszentrum. Die haben mich einmal herumgeführt durch alle Abteilungen. Da hat immer der Abteilungsleiter gesagt, was sie jetzt gerade machen. Und die konnten das erklären. Das fand ich sehr erstaunlich oder sensationell, ich habe das noch nie mitgekriegt. Also praktisch, wenn man irgendwo in eine andere Fakultät geht, also...
Wie kam es denn zu IBM?
Zufall. Ein Student kam vorbei und hat gesagt, das ist die Stelle seiner Zukunft. Also man soll Dr. mit Auszeichnung bestanden haben. Paar Jahre Postdoc. Englisch können usw. Und dann kann man die Informatik des 21. Jahrhunderts erforschen, stand in der Zeit. Ich habe eigentlich gar keine Bewerbung gelesen. Kam so ein Student und hat gesagt, guck das wäre mein Traum. Das solltest du vielleicht tun. Da hatte ich mich gerade geärgert, dass ich mal wieder auf Platz 2 von der Berufungsliste war. Und dann habe mich mein Gores-Mühle-Blog??? - ich hatte so mit Wasserzeichen so ein schönes Papier – und dann habe ich handschriftlich geschrieben, hallo IBM, ich bin jetzt schon etwas über 30 Jahre alt, habe eine Frau, zwei Kinder, bin Professor für Mathematik und wahrscheinlich überqualifiziert und wollt ihr mich trotzdem?
Das war dann wann jetzt?
Das war 86. Da hatten wir gerade den Johannes, der ist gerade geboren. War erst mal ein Baby ein sehr aktives Baby. Er hat uns alle all night long aufrechterhalten. Da habe ich meine besten Forschungsergebnisse erzielt, also in völlig übermüdetem Zustand. Weil er irgendwie 5-6 mal spielen wollte in der Nacht. Und so in der Zeit bin ich hingegangen und habe mich einfach, ich habe so einen Brief hingeschickt. Das war nicht so fertig irgendwie der Entschluss. Die haben dann angerufen am nächsten Tag gleich, also nicht irgendwie nach acht Wochen, wie das heute manchmal ist. Sondern am nächsten Tag hat einer angerufen, er soll mal was anständiges schicken, haben sie meiner Frau gesagt.
Und nicht nur so einen Brief.
Ja und dann habe ich normal meine Papiere eingereicht und dann ist das dann so eine lange Freundschaft geworden. Ich bin war so echt begeistert – wie soll man das sagen – zwei Sachen, also einmal, dass die alle erklären konnten, was sie machten, also die Mathematik dazu und auch die Fachlichkeit. Die machten so gerade Expertensysteme für Nierentransplantation, also wer wann zur Klinik gefahren muss, wenn er welche Daten genau hat. Also man muss gucken, wie die Patienten zueinander passen, also die Lebern, die die zur Verfügung stellen. Also dass die biologisch verträglich sind und dann muss man irgendwie noch Tourenplanung reinmachen, also dass die Leber auch noch eintreffen kann und lebt noch. Und das ist ein schwieriges Optimierungsproblem und da haben sie dann so was mit den Kliniken in Heidelberg zusammen gemacht.
Und das konnten ja alles o richtig erklären und da war auch das Problem im Vordergrund, gar nicht so sehr die Theorie. Also natürlich muss man dann bestimmte Theorien anziehen, aber man löst erst mal das Problem. Das hat mich total fasziniert. Ich bin dann mit schwarzem Anzug gekommen, weil das ja so ist, muss man ja bei Bewerbungen.
Generell oder bei IBM?
Ich habe das gedacht. Also ich war einmal bei Siemens und da hatten sie alle schwarze Anzüge an. Das ist glaube ich so eine Attitüde von Ingenieuren, Mathematiker nicht so. Ingenieure sind immer echt gut angezogen.
Also bei IBM auf jeden Fall?
Bei Siemens.
IBM auch. Damals schon oder nicht?
Habe ich gedacht, das ist so big blue. Und da gehe ich da mit dem schwarzen Anzug hin und dann hat der Boss aber nur gesagt, hallo Leute, da kommt jetzt einer und hält mal einen schönen Vortrag über Informationstheorie, kommt alle in die Bibliothek und dann war das so heiß, Anfang Mai so wie heute und glaube so 10. Mai rum …
Und die saßen da alle in T-Shirts. Also ich habe geschwitzt. Die saßen alle in kurzen Hosen und in T-Shirts da und haben sich gefreut und es war so richtig so total schön und da habe ich gesagt, da fange ich an zu arbeiten. Das war einfach klar. Ich habe gesagt, hoffentlich verzeiht mir bitte, dass ich jetzt ganz falsch angezogen bin, haben gelacht, ist dein Problem und dann haben wir den Vortrag gehalten.
Schwitzt man erst mal ein bisschen.
Und der Vortrag war sozusagen die Bewerbungsrede für den Job?
Nicht Bewerbung, wollten einfach nur mal kennenlernen. Also praktisch, man hat so eine Idee.
Also Sie sind jetzt nicht gleich sozusagen mit dem neuen Job wieder zur Tür rausgegangen, sondern es ergab sich dann erst danach.
Ja.
Und was wollten die haben? Also wofür braucht IBM damals den Mathematiker?
Damals gab es eine ganze Serie von ganz großen Forschungsprojekten, also wo IBM quasi dem Desi??? oder Kernforschungsanlage Jülich und so Großforschungseinrichtungen. Mehrere Mainframes, also für Wetterprognose für den Wetterdienst und so weiter gegeben hat. Und das ging über Parallelrechnen, also ganz große Mainframes mit mehreren Parallelprozessoren, das war so am Anfang der ganzen Geschichte. Und da gab es eigentlich keinen, der die richtig bedienen konnte. Weil man ja ein anderes Betriebssystem hat. Man muss auch die Parallelprozessoren jetzt ganz neu programmieren, damit die auch parallel arbeiten und nicht sequentiell. Da habe ich ja zwar zig Prozessoren, also damals so 8 oder 16 – 32.
Und die liegen dann nur am Strand und langweilen sich.
Dann muss man natürlich die so programmieren, dass die alle gleichzeitig arbeiten. Das ist dann eine ganz andere Art zu denken und zu programmieren und Computer kosteten dann viele Millionen und da hat IBM dann Kooperationsverträge abgeschlossen, dass dann immer so 2-3 für 3 Jahre für die mitgearbeitet haben. Also für die kaufende Institution.
Und das war dann sozusagen der Job, Software zu entwickeln?
Das war dann der Job.
Software zu entwickeln?
Ich habe dann gleich selber so viele Ideen gehabt, dass sie mich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen in Ruhe gelassen haben. Also ich habe gar nicht so sehr in diesen offiziellen Problemen mitgearbeitet und wollte ich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig. Ich habe damals so das Gefühl gehabt, das ist Spielerei, Parallelprogrammierung für 8 oder 16 Computer zu bauen. Und ich habe so das Gefühl gehabt, dass in 20 Jahren dann das was im Mainframe ist, es bei Aldi zu kaufen gibt. Das hat sich auch bewahrheitet. Da hatte ich so das Gefühl, das ist so ein bisschen Forschung, die für 10 Jahre vielleicht gebraucht wird, aber dann kann man sie in die Mülltonne werfen. Weil man damals schon sah, dass man dann vielleicht zu vielen Prozessoren kommt oder 1000e oder dass man eine Cloud hat oder so. Und dass die Programmiererfordernisse, also welchen Prozessor spricht man jetzt an vielleicht irgendwo ganz anders werden.
Ja das Problem ist immer noch nicht so richtig gelöst, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Nein, jetzt hat man ja, also es gibt ... bei SHP wird das jetzt hochgetrieben. Also SHP-Hana??? da hat man ja die Idee, dass man die Algorithmen mit der Datenbank alle in den Chip kriegt. Also heute man ja eine Hauptspeichergröße von vielleicht 64GB und da ist der Hauptspeiche von dem Prozessor so groß, dass man praktisch den ganzen Inhalt der Festplatte gleich mit reinladen kann und im Grunde die mathematischen Berechnungen gleich auf dem Chip selber machen kann, wenn ich auf die Festplatte zugreife habe ich ja so was wie Millisekunden Zugriffszeit und auf den Chip Nanosekunden und dann bin ich natürlich um Faktor vielleicht 1000 schneller oder so was. Und da gibt es jetzt Bestrebungen, das Ganze gleich im Chip stattfinden zu lassen. Das gibt dann wieder eine ganz andere Art von Programmierung.
Und das ist so ein bisschen, für mich war das immer so ein bisschen Zeitabschnittswichtigkeit. Und ich wollte gerne so ein bisschen an was ewigem forschen, also was ein bisschen bleibt oder nicht gleich wegkommt.
Abgesehen davon, dass man jetzt Leute getroffen hat, die in der Lage waren, zu beschreiben, was sie tun, was ja immer sehr schön ist, wie unterschiedlich war denn die Wissenschaftswelt und die Wirtschaftswelt damals bei diesem Wechsel. Ich meine, IBM mag vielleicht noch ein Spezialfall sein, aber ich versuche es jetzt eher so ein bisschen allgemein.
Ich war dann praktisch wie in der Uni, aber irgendwie das war viel interessanter. Man hatte auch mehr Spaß auch zu arbeiten. Man hat auch Außenkontakt gehabt, mit den Leuten, die die Probleme hatten. Also ich habe eine Zeit lang Industrieoptimierung gemacht. Also wir haben so was wie Fahrpläne, Flugpläne, Stahlwerkspläne optimiert. Ja so die ersten Navis gebaut, Standortberatung gemacht und das hatte so den Vorteil, dass ich in so große Konzerne reingekommen bin und die haben mir ganz genau erklärt, was sie da machen. Also wie ein Fließband jetzt ganz genau funktioniert. Und da habe ich halt unglaublich viel gelernt. Also nach welchen Regeln das geht und was die Probleme sind, wenn da so ein Arbeiter irgendwas macht.
Da kommt irgendwie so ein Auftrag, kannst du nicht mal von irgendwelchen Hofbräu die LKW-Fahrer optimieren. Also dass die nicht so viel durch die Gegend fahren und die Fässer abladen. Dann fährt man da mal ein Tag mit und dann habe ich festgestellt, also nur nach Stoppuhr oder muss man noch nicht mal eine Stoppuhr haben, dass die fast die ganze Zeit drauf geht, gar nicht mit dem Bierabladen und auch nicht das Bier hinfahren, sondern die müssen fast die ganze Zeit mit dem Gastwirt kungeln, dass er endlich Bargeld rausgibt und die wollen das nicht auf Kredit oder Kreditkarte bezahlen, sondern immer nur in Bar, weil die Restaurants ja – das sieht man im Fernsehen ja dauernd jetzt heute – dass die dauernd pleite gehen. Und dann kommen sie mit den Bierfässern und dann kommt einer raus und jammert erst mal, könnt ihr nicht noch einmal anschreiben lassen. Nein und so, und dann diskutieren sie erst mal.
Und die Lösung, mathematisch brauchte man keine Lösung, kann man sagen, erst einer mit dem Motorrad vorwegfahren und man bringt das Bier nur dahin, wo er das Geld schon hat. Ja und so. Und dann hat man sich diese ganzen Abläufe angeguckt und manchmal sind sehr sehr schwierige mathematische Lösungen raus gekommen und manchmal konnte man das aber auch einfach so lösen.
Aber Mathe war schon so im Kern auch die Tätigkeit.
Mathe war im Kern schon da. Also ich habe nur diese, ich war dann als Abteilungschef so ein bisschen der Erstverkäufer und habe mir erst mal das Problem angeguckt, ob wir da irgendwas machen können und ob wir das von der Komplexität überhaupt lösen können mathematisch und ob der Kunde das überhaupt will. Dann hat es so interessante Wendungen gegeben. Die Leute haben Angst, dass wir das gar nicht verbessern können, dann ist das Geld sinnlos rausgegeben. Und noch größere Furcht, das hat mich irgendwie bewegt dann fast in die Philosophie oder Psychologie zu gehen, noch schlimmer war es, dass sie eigentlich noch mehr Angst hatten, dass wir das zu gut können.
Also wenn man irgendwo in den Anschein, in den Geruch gerät, des mehr als 20% zu verbessern, dann kriegen die Leute kalte Füße, weil sie denken, jetzt werden wir beschuldigt. Also die haben nicht so sagen sich, also man könnte doch naiv freudig sein, also so als Mathematiker war wir das erst. Wir haben gesagt, wow wir können das hier ein Viertel verbessern, 25% guck mal. Da sind wir unser Geld wert, wir kommen dann so wie Heroes. Wir kommen da rein, gucken hin, arbeiten fünf Monate und es ist 25% besser. Und wir sind alle stolz und der Kunde von uns der freut sich und verdient über alle Kante Geld. Das ist nicht so gewesen. Also praktisch wenn wir kamen und dann sagen sie, wie viel wird das besser und dann beten sie irgendwie, dass es nicht so viel besser wird, weil sie irgendwie das Gefühl  haben, sie werden beschuldigt, dass es so schlimm ist.
Beschuldigt von wem?
Das war mir nie so richtig klar, aber man hätte es ja politisch besser erklären können oder so. Ich wollte ja nur für IBM dann das Geld für den Auftrag. Den Ruhm sozusagen, dass wir das verbessert hätten …
Aber ich meine, woher kommt diese Angst, dass es sich zu sehr verbessern könnte, was man eigentlich verbessern möchte? Weil es dann so aussieht, dass man es vorher zu schlecht gemacht hat?
Das ist irgendwie so ein Vorwurf. Ja genau.
Wie kann es sein, dass da so viel Luft drin war?
Wie kann das sein? Ja und da ist oft so viel Luft drin, weil man einfach einen ganz katastrophalen Intuitionsfehler gemacht hat.
Der dann im Rahmen der Softwareverarbeitung rauskam.
Der kommt dann raus, wenn man es optimiert. Den haben wir auch nicht gesehen. Weil wir haben einmal eine Lösung gehabt, wo die Standorte von einem Großhandel, die haben wir ausgerechnet, dass wir die besser machen. Also wir haben alle Kunden, wo man das hinfahren muss und dann macht man eine Analyse, wo genau die Lager hin müssen. Und in der Regel machen die da Fehler dabei. Also früher hat man die Lager immer in die Innenstädte gelegt. Das ist nicht gut, man muss sie auf Autobahnkreuze vor die Städte legen, weil man dann in einer Stunde fantastisch viel weiter fahren kann. Dann braucht man viel weniger Lager. Und dann kommt man so, beim Großhandel haben wir dann eine Lösung bekommen, wo die Lager auf 5 Meter genau oder auf Millimeter genau optimal waren.
Also ich gebe die ganze Struktur von dem Konzern ein, rechne die Standorte aus und dann sind die irgendwie einen Meter neben den jetzigen ganz genau. Und dann haben wir da wochenlang gesessen, das kann nicht sein, dass einer also aus Zufall.
Genau das getroffen hat, was auch das mathematische Modell ausspuckt.
Ja und dann kommt raus, das hat diesen Job so interessant gemacht, es kam raus, dass der Grund dafür war, dass das Verkaufsbüro von dem Vertreter das war immer oben im Lager. Und diese Vertreter haben irgendwie das natürliche Talent, ganz genau radial die Umgebung anzuwerben, dass sie Kunde sind.
Ah das hat sich also sozusagen aus dem Standort heraus ergeben, dass ihre Kunden genau da waren.
Ja weil der Verkäufer im Lager war. Und dann kommt eine ganz andere Lösung raus. Und dann muss man natürlich, wenn man mehr Umsatz machen will, das ist relativ einfach jetzt, also wie man Umsatz machen will, man schmeißt den Verkäufer raus. Also man guckt sich irgendeine weiße Fläche an, wo gar kein Kunde ist und gibt ihm da ein Büro.
Damit er dort...
Ja und dann fängt er da an, wieder alle anzuwerben. Das Problem ist, dass die finden, dass man ihnen das nicht zumuten kann, er hat da jetzt immer gut gearbeitet. Dann sage ich, passt mal auf, wollt ihr jetzt den Umsatz verdoppeln oder was? Ja das ist so ein Fall, wo dann die Menschheit sagt, das wollen die nicht. Also der hat da jetzt das Büro. Und der sagt, der wohnt da jetzt auch. Wir sagen, aber du musst jetzt einfach weg.
Weil sonst wird es ja nicht besser.
Sagen die, nein das machen sie nicht. Und das kann ich jetzt bis heute Abend 12 Uhr lauter so Geschichten erzählen, wo die Leute dann zwar den Umsatz verdoppeln wollen, man kann das auch sagen, wie das geht, also jetzt da war es nicht verdoppeln, aber man versteht doch locker, dass man das 10-20% höher kriegt, wenn man ihn irgendwo anders hin wohnen lässt. Und dann sagt die Wirklichkeit, nein so genau wollen wir das nicht wissen. Dann sagen sie, schreib das mal als Studie auf, macht mal 100 PowerPoints davon und dann schließen sie es weg.
Nichts desto trotz diese Zeit von der wir jetzt reden, die 80er Jahre.
Das war jetzt so bis 95. Wir haben dann mehrere...
In die 90er Jahre rein, ich wollte kurz sagen, das ist ja schon jetzt im Rückblick kann man sagen, das war schon die Zeit des ersten großen Umbruchs. Ich meine Computer gab es schon irgendwie immer, war ja schon immer ein Thema irgendwie in den 50ern/60ern, aber sie waren halt irgendwie nicht da. Auch als ich irgendwie groß geworden bin Anfang der 80er Jahre, jeder wusste zwar, dass es Computer gibt, aber man sah keine. Und auf einmal waren sie irgendwie da und auf einmal fingen sie halt auch an, quasi Zukunftsplanung zu beeinflussen, eben auf eine Art und Weise wie das eben so bisher kaum irgendeine Technologie getan hat. Also ich denke, das einzige was man überhaupt noch vergleichen könnte wäre vielleicht Elektrizität und das Telefon, aber in dem Moment, wo die Computer sich so richtig entfaltet hatten, brach es ja auch vor allem fast in jeder Branche in irgendeiner Form um.
Und seitdem sehen wir uns in zunehmendem Maße mit irgendwie immer stärker werdenden Wellen solchen Wandlungsdrucks konfrontiert. War das irgendwie so auch wenn man so in dem System so sitzt bei IBM genauso wahrnehmbar oder war da einfach alles normal?
Wir hatten damals halt diese Großrechner. Also das war halt sehr teuer, also mehrere Millionen. Dann hatte jeder von meiner Abteilung dann bald so eine Workstation, RS6000???, wenn es einen interessiert, die kosteten aber so um die 200.000 Mark noch, also pro Person. Und dann hat man einen wahnsinnigen Kostenblock halt sozusagen für die Wissenschaft. Also es kann sein, dass das noch so in der Gegend von Gehaltskosten war, einfach der Computer. Und das ist halt sehr sehr teuer. Also der richtige Umbruch kam dann erst, als man das mit normalen PCs auch machen konnte. Dann ist sozusagen das teurere weg und es ist dazu gekommen, vielleicht so dass irgendwie 1993 das SRPR3??? gekommen ist über die Menschheit.
Also die Software, mit der die Betriebe ihre ganzen internen Abläufe gemacht haben.
Ja das R2 war ja auch auf Großrechnern so von IBM implementiert. Und da kann man sich Vorträge von Hasso Plattner angucken. Durch irgendein Problem mit der Lieferung von Mainframes hatten sie Schwierigkeiten irgendwo einem Großkunden SHP zu liefern und es gab aber jede Menge Workstations und dann haben sie gesagt, verteilen Sie das ganze mal auf Workstations zur Probe für diesen Kunden und da ist dann so eine Idee geboren worden, fast so aus einer Notlage heraus, dass man das SHP dann verteilt auf verschiedene kleinere Computer. Und da war irgendwo dann relativ schnell die Idee geboren, dass jeder sein SHP am besten jetzt heute auf dem Handy hat. Und das ist relativ schnell gekommen. Und dann war sozusagen die Betriebswirtschaft jetzt überall. Also praktisch in jedem PC und auch dann auf jedem Arbeitsplatz und ich glaube, das hat einen erheblichen Unterschied gemacht.
Nicht nur technisch, sondern auch in der Geisteshaltung. Man sagt ja heute, dass die BWLer langsam die Macht übernommen haben gegenüber den Ingenieuren. Weil plötzlich diese ganzen Analyse- und Kontrollwerkzeuge, Planungswerkzeuge überall da waren. Heute stand gerade in der Zeitung, dass der 9. DAX-Konzern jetzt seinen Finanzchef zu Oberboss gemacht hat. Also praktisch der ganze Computersiegeszug ist nicht nur so auf der technischen Ebene, sondern auch wie man ein Business betreibt. Also mit BigData und dann mit Zahlen usw. Und dann mit vielen vielen Rechenschiebern. Und man hatte am liebsten so was wie ein Flugzeugcockpit vor sich, so ein Herrscherdingsda mit allen möglichen Hebeln und schraubt dann an allen Grafiken dran rum und gibt dem nur Befehle.
Und so Leute wie ich sagen, komm doch lieber mal wieder zu den Brauereifahrzeugen an und guck es dir an. Ja also wenn man gewisse Dinge nicht aus den Zahlen sehen kann, sondern wie die Leute sich dann bei der Arbeit benehmen, muss man vielleicht dann auch mal vor Ort dann sich anschauen.
Gibt es denn schon Erkenntnisse darüber, wie effizient die neuen Herren der Zahlen ihre Unternehmen führen?
Das tun sie sehr gut. Es ist nur das Problem mit dem Internet ist, dass es sehr viel Wandel erzeugt und das steht in den Zahlen nicht drin. Also die Zahlen geben ja irgendwo, also wenn man aktuell ist, also bis heute die Zahlen, den Stand der Wirklichkeit wieder. Man muss aber nicht nur das Zeug, also das Tagesgeschäft vernünftig in den Griff kriegen, das kann man mit den ganzen Zahlen. Man muss irgendwie auch planen, was man in der Zukunft sein will und das sieht man aus den Zahlen nicht. Und da muss man also, wenn man jetzt nur die Zahlen gewöhnt ist, sieht man irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Also man muss wirklich dann irgendwo in die Zukunft gucken.
Beispiel. Glühbirnenhersteller macht immer so E27 Glühbirnen und dann machen sie als nächstes Sparglühbirnen oder Halogen irgendwas. Und dann kommt plötzlich so ein Bruchpunkt, der sehr schwierig ist, dann kommen LED-Leuchten und LED-Leuchten gehen eigentlich nicht mehr kaputt, die muss ich in die Lampe rein bauen. Und in diesem Moment muss der, was vorher ein Ingenieur ist, plötzlich Kunst studieren, weil die Lampe ja wegen der Schönheit gekauft wird. Also vorher war die Schönheit und das Ingenieurszeug getrennt, weil man die Glühbirne ja rein schraubt und jetzt ist plötzlich die Technologie mit der Schönheit zusammen. Und da kann man ganze Konzerne hinten rausfallen sehen. Weil plötzlich so ein Haufen von Ingenieuren ist und die anderen sind ein Haufen Künstler und jetzt muss man sagen, jetzt arbeitet mal plötzlich zusammen.
Und da merkt man so wie ganze Kulturen sich nicht annähern können oder sich nicht mischen können. Oder die haben auch keine Lust dazu oder sie fangen dann an, so Rangeleien zu machen oder so. Und dann sagt einer, dann mach mal deine Kunst da und dann sag uns nur, was wir da rein schrauben müssen und so geht das nicht. Die müssen dann nicht nur interdisziplinär arbeiten, also das Wort ist schon ganz abgelutscht. Also dieses was die sagen, dass man verschiedene Disziplinen zusammenlegen muss, das ist nicht der Punkt, sondern das sind Geisteshaltungen. Also ich habe jetzt so ein Beispiel genommen, wo die Geisteshaltung des Ingenieurs, der immer nur auf seine Effizienzen guckt, das ist A++ oder irgendwas wird und schön leuchtet und die Farbe muss richtig sein nach Wunsch usw. Und dann kommen plötzlich Künstler. Jetzt kommen noch so die Spielkinder die Informatiker dazu, die machen jetzt Lampen, die in verschiedenen Farben sind und dann kann man Ruhetöne oder weiß ich Sauna imitieren.
Was bei Philips jetzt anfängt. Da bilden sich ganz andere Denk- oder Wirtschafts- oder Verhaltenskulturen und das finde ich, für mich ist das so das spannende Feld, also wo ich mich dann viel mit befasse. Und ich sehe, dass es ganz ganz grotesk große Schwierigkeiten gibt für Konzerne, die in so eine Falle kommen. Also wo man sozusagen die Geisteshaltung wechseln muss. Also zum Beispiel Apple hat das gekonnt, dass die auf Ästhetik gehen.
Ich würde das gar nicht mehr so sehr daran festmachen, dass man jetzt irgendwas mehr betont, sondern es ist glaube ich eher auch so ein bisschen die Frage, was machen wir eigentlich und der Glühbirnenhersteller hat sich halt genau dafür gehalten. Er hat sich als Glühbirnenhersteller gehalten und hat erst später vielleicht verstanden, wenn es dann überhaupt noch rechtzeitig war, dass er eigentlich ein Lichtlösungsdienstleister war, wo man halt vorher eben Glühbirnen herstellen musste, aber später andere Sachen tun musste und dieses permanente sich selbst in Frage stellen und sich im Zeichen des technologischen und auch gesellschaftlichen Wandels immer wieder die eigene Position, was ist eigentlich mein Beitrag hier zum Gesellschafts- oder Wirtschaftsleben genau, dass man das immer wieder in Frage stellt und auch bereit ist, das bisher gedachte komplett zu verwerfen.
Ja zum Beispiel bei Lebensmitteln gibt es ja so ein Bereich, wo man sich dafür interessiert, was da drin ist. Also was man da isst. Oder bei Whisky ganz genau Single Malt von Schottland, das ist dann in so ???fässern 18 Monate. Und kann man alles lernen, wie viele Punkte das dann hat bei Michael Jackson und so. Und dann sage ich zum Beispiel kommen plötzlich neue Welten auf, das ist bei Tee so. Da gibt es jetzt Tee, das weiß ich überhaupt nicht wie das schmeckt und was da drin ist, da steht aber, dieser Tee verbreitet Glück und der Seligkeit oder der bereitet mich auf morgen auf den Stress vor oder kann sein, vielleicht gibt es schon Prüfungsangsttee. Und die Leute kaufen das. Und dann kann man natürlich sagen, wenn man so früher mit Tee, Whiskey oder so Bescheid weiß, dann sagt man, das ist aber Dreck. Guck mal, was soll Prüfungsangsttee.
Dann sage ich, pass auf die kaufen das aber, dann sagen sie, das kannst du nicht wollen. Ich habe in vielen Branchen so Diskussionen geführt, weil die sagen, so was wie Monster habe ich – ich habe Aktien gekauft, ich habe gesagt, ich zeig es euch, ich kaufe jetzt Aktien vor euren Augen.
Monster.
Von?
Diese Dosen, die Energydrinks mit dem M.
Von Monster?
Kenn ich gar nicht.
Das ist so die amerikanische Variante von Red Bull.
Und da sagen alle, das schmeckt ja nicht, also Red Bull oder das, aber die nehmen es einfach, weiß ich nicht, das gibt Lebensgefühl und das kann zum Beispiel sein, dass für eine gewisse Generation der Geschmack gar nicht so eine Rolle spielt, da ist einfach wichtig, dass da jetzt Beruhigung ... also früher hat man Bekunis??? Beruhigung oder irgendwas getrunken und heute ist das so wieder anders. Und dieser Wechsel, das hat noch gar nichts mit Internet zu tun, aber der Wechsel auch in diesen Dingen fällt den Firmen ungeheuer schwer. Also wenn man jetzt gefühlt, ich bin ein Teehaus, und bei mir kommt da nicht Prüfungsangsttee drauf und andere sagen, komm das wollen die Leute so.
Verstehe.
Ja man ist halt mehr Gefühlsdienstleister.
Der andere sagt, Darjeeling Second Flush, sonst trink ich gar nichts. Also die echten Liebhaber. Ich verstehe das schon und dann kommt wieder so was. Und man verschätzt das. Also eine Weile waren ja, das ist ja dann verboten worden, aber Alcopops oder so was, so elende Mischgetränke, was eigentlich nicht das ist, was so ein Erzeuger von wertvollem Rum im Mindset hat. Und das Spannende in der heutigen Zeit ist, dass praktisch kein Mindset irgendwie mehr so länger bleibt. Also man muss wirklich sehr gucken und es kann sein, dass man mit einer gewissen Denkrichtung oder Haltung zu irgendwas vielleicht in fünf Jahren einfach weg ist.
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal auf den Elefant im Raum hinweisen. Das Internet, das kam ja dann irgendwann. Was mich mal interessieren würde, was war der erste Moment, wo Sie so auf das Internet gestoßen sind als solches und aber auch das Internet irgendwas getan hat oder abgestrahlt hat, wo Sie gedacht haben, oh wow.
Wir haben es eigentlich nur benutzt.
Ja aber es muss ja irgendwann mal auch irgendwie, ich unterstelle das jetzt mal, dass man irgendwann mal auf das Netz stößt und überrascht ist von dem was es tut, leistet, weiterleitet, kommuniziert, macht, mit einem macht oder mit anderen Leuten macht.
Also ich glaube das war bei mir jetzt erst so Ende der 90er.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Was hat es da getan?
Ich habe ja immer nur diese ganzen Konzernketten versucht, mit Mathematik zu reorganisieren. Und dann kam irgendwo das Internet. Was mich eher fasziniert hat sind die neuen Businessmodelle davon. Ich war dann auch der Erstzeichner von Amazon. Das fand ich eine gute Idee. Ich war schon, ich hatte allerdings, ich bin aufgekaufter Kunde, ich war bei Buchonline.de oder irgendwie hieß das, von Regensburg. Und irgendwann hat man mir mitgeteilt, ich sei jetzt Kunde von Amazon Deutschland, also die sind aufgekauft, das war dann die Zweigkeimstelle???, also die Deutschen waren da schneller, nur Amazon war völlig radikaler. Und die sind dann so an die Börse gegangen. Ich habe auch die ersten Aktien gezeichnet, ziemlich viel Geld verdient, die sind ja dann ziemlich gleich hochgestiegen. Nicht gleich, wollte auch keiner haben, man konnte beliebig viele haben, es war gar kein Hype. Also wenn man sich erinnert.
Bei Google kriegte man ja dann gar keine mehr, bei Facebook sowieso nicht oder Twitter. Bei Amazon hätte man sein ganzes Vermögen in Erstaktien der Amazon geben können, war genug da. Also keiner wollte das haben. Die sind auch erst so um 10% gefallen und dann so langsam angezogen. Da gab es dann so relativ viel Hass, dass das nie was wird. Also man hat immer gesagt, das ist keine reale Firma, die besteht nur aus Software, das ist nicht Brick und ???, wie man dann sagt, also kann gegen so was wie Karstadt mit Innenstadtgrundstücken nie standhalten. Man denke jetzt an Karstadt, 15 Jahre hat es gedauert. Und das hat mich so ein bisschen empört, dass dieses Neue was da vom Internet kommt, so runter gemacht wurde. Also dann kam so als erste Suchmaschine Yahoo und so weiter. Ich habe dann angefangen wie wahnsinnig im Internet zu lernen. Wir hatten damals AltaVista.
Als Suchmaschine.
Als Suchmaschine. Und mein Schlüsselerlebnis war ein bisschen bei Businessmodellen, ich habe Besuch gehabt von einem jungen Mitarbeiter, der hat damals gesagt, jetzt bricht ein neuer Hype aus, er weiß jetzt, was demnächst gekauft werden muss. Und da habe ich gesagt, was heißt das? Er hat gesagt, ich weiß nicht was es ist, es heißt Enterprise Application Integration, EAI und ich habe keine Ahnung was es ist, aber der Vortrag dadrüber war irgendwie überzeugend, aber ich habe schon wieder vergessen was es war. Und dann habe ich bei AltaVista 20, also ich weiß heute noch, 19 Hits bei AltaVista gefunden, EAI, 19. Und zwei davon waren erschöpfend auskunftsfähig. Und da habe ich gesagt, das ist die Zukunft. Also so richtig jetzt, ich habe es gewusst. Und dann bin zu dem Geschäftsführern einem nach dem anderen gegangen und habe gesagt, Enterprise das bringts.
Also dass man die Anwendung irgendwie über ... was heute Cloud, also das war schon so eine Idee, dass man die Anwendungen alle zusammenschrauben muss und eine gemeinsame Grundlage, einen gemeinsamen Datenpool machen muss und dass man dann die Unternehmen ganz neu organisiert, durch diese Integration der verschiedenen Anwendungen. Das war eine total gute Idee. Und dann musste man so Messagepipes und Messenger machen zwischen den verschiedenen Datenbanken, also was jetzt alles Cloudcomputing so im Prinzip macht. Und das ist 1999 raus gekommen. Die Leute haben gesagt, das haben sie noch nie gehört, da muss ich einen Hörfehler gehabt haben. Ich habe gesagt, aber das ist eine gute Idee. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja aber wenn es noch keiner kennt, kann es keine gute Idee sein. Dann habe ich jeden Morgen bei AltaVista nachgeguckt, Enterprise Application Integration immer mit der gleichen Schreibweise und die Hits gezählt und das ist dann bis Juni/Juli auf 3000 und im Oktober auf 6000.
Dann habe ich irgendwo gesagt, und dann bin ich immer mutiger geworden und habe gesagt, das. Und dann haben sie gesagt, das ist keine Marktforschung, das kannst du nicht machen. Das bedeutet nicht, wenn da mehr Hits. So was heute Googletrends wäre, das haben wir damals alles selber so quasi erfunden, also praktisch, wie man das Internet benutzt, was man damit macht, wie man Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt, was die Leute da tun, welche Businessmodelle gut sind usw. Und das habe ich alles angeschaut. Ich habe mich hauptsächlich für Businessmodelle interessiert und immer gesurft und gelernt und was die Leute da machten und dann haben sie angefangen, Autos im Internet, Autoweb.com gab es so eine Firma. Und dann habe ich immer überlegt sozusagen die Probleme, die man heute schon verstanden hat. Also wenn einer ein Auto auf dem Web verkaufen will, müssen ja 10.000 gucken und ein Auto suchen. Das war damals nicht.
Dann hat man irgendwie 10 Leute, die ein Auto suchen und 100, die eins verkaufen. Aber das matcht nicht, also das geht erst, wenn es so ganz groß wird als Infrastruktur. Das haben damals die Leute nicht verstanden und haben einfach Werbung gemacht. Haben sie einfach 100 Millionen Kapital eingesammelt und nur Werbeanzeige gemacht, aber die meisten Leute haben dann trotzdem kein Auto auf dem Internet verkauft und dann ist die Firma einfach ersatzlos bankrott gegangen. Und das war dann der .com Crash. Das war im Grunde ein vollkommener Irrtum in den Businessmodellen, man hat gedacht, die werden so schnell von der Bevölkerung adaptiert. Und da hat man jetzt einfach diese seit dem .com Crash hat man das jetzt alles gelernt und die Bevölkerung ist jetzt langsam da.
Und jetzt kommt alles was so 1999 bis 2002 pleite gegangen ist unter großem Tamtam kommt ja jetzt wieder. Also die Ideen Carsharing oder Bildtelefon, das hat man ja mit dem Skype fast im Handy. Alle diese Ideen wurden ja damals angefangen und sind mangels Masse gestorben oder mangels auch Akzeptanz oder Begeisterung in der Bevölkerung und das kann man nicht mit Werbeanzeigen lösen. Sie haben damals gedacht, sie machen das so wie Margarinereklame, kauf Rama oder so und dann ist denen das alles...
Ja werden sie schon alle loslaufen.
Und da haben sie das ganze Geld verbrannt und diese ganzen Ideen habe ich ja noch von früher so im Kopf und die kommen jetzt alle wieder. Die waren nicht schlecht, man hat nur gedacht, man kriegt das einfach mit Werbung hin und das tut es nicht.
Ja das ist ganz interessant. Die Gesellschaft teilt sich dann glaube ich auch recht gut in die Leute auf, die dem Internet viel zu viel zuschreiben und vielleicht dann halt in the long run dann auch wirklich richtig liegen, aber auch vollkommen falsch einschätzen, wann diese Zeitpunkte der Akzeptanz gekommen sind, aber da vielleicht auch mit so einem Grundoptimismus auch ran gehen, da würde ich mich selber fast noch mit dazuzählen. Auf der anderen Seite die Dauerpessimisten, die da auch halt immer die Zahl des Satans sozusagen am Horizont sehen, weil diese Technologien halt irgendwie alles auflösen. Sei es nur so der Status Quo des Verkäufers im ersten Stock. Oder eben auch sozusagen das Selbstverständnis eines Unternehmens oder eben auch vielleicht das Selbstverständnis auch einer Bildungseinrichtung. Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass auch so im Bildungsbereich, im universitären Bereich auch teilweise das Internet mit all seinen Konsequenzen eben an manchen Stellen auch als Bedrohung angesehen wird.
Ja ist es ja so ein bisschen.
Ja aber was ist denn bedroht dadurch?
Ich habe in meinem ersten Schrifttum, das ist von meinem ersten Artikel über die Bedeutung des Internet 1998 habe ich den geschrieben, das ist meine erste Kolumne im Informatikspektrum, die schreibe ich immer noch. Der Artikel ist so gut angekommen, dann haben sie gesagt, der soll noch einen schreiben und da habe ich noch einen geschrieben und dann ist es bis heute geblieben. Also alle zwei Monate.
Rundum Businessintellegence. Also wie der Computer Klugheit da in die Welt bringen kann in verschiedenen Aspekten. Da steht auch schon zum Beispiel drin, also praktisch man sollte alle Vorlesungen der Welt von einem weltmeisterlichen Superexperten so wie Einstein mal konservieren und da habe ich ganz frech geschrieben, dass Einstein konserviert auch 50 Jahre alt immer noch besser ist als so ein durchschnittlicher normal habilitierter Professor an einer mittelmäßigen Hochschule in Deutschland ist. Also es kann sein, dass es immer noch Professoren gibt, die live irgendwie ein total gutes Erlebnis übergeben, also ich will das jetzt gar nicht abstreiten, das ist jetzt immer das Problem, sie sagen immer, es gibt noch Professoren, die total gute Vorlesungen halten und ich habe immer gegengehalten, wenn man aber Einstein oder Sigmund Freud selber oder Max Planck selber die Vorlesung halten lässt, dann ist das in der Konserve immer noch besser als ein durchschnittlicher Mensch.
Und was war der Titel davon?
Und es kann dann eben auch kommen, dass eine wunderbare Lehreinheit im Gymnasium, einfach als YouTube-Film besser ist als so ein durchschnittlicher Lehrer an einem normalen Gymnasium. Und da gibt es immer so der Kampf ist immer, dass die richtig guten Lehrer sagen, das glauben sie nie. Die anderen Lehrer klopfen Beifall, aber im Grunde die Masse ist schon gar nicht so gut glaube ich, wie das beste im Internet, wenn man das wirklich machen würde. Und natürlich gibt es da Bedrohungsszenarien. Ich meine man könnte es ja so machen, wie bei der Führerscheinprüfung, weil wenn man beim Führerschein ist es so, dass man einfach die Prüfung macht, also der Staat mischt sich da ja nicht ein. Ich muss mir irgendwie selber schnitzen, dass ich das theoretisch in den Kopf kriege und mache Tests im Internet und dann bestehe ich die theoretische Prüfung.
Und dann nehme ich mir irgendwo Fahrstunden, bezahle die und mach die Prüfung.
An der Uni?
Ich kann natürlich solche Modelle auch denken. Also dass man sagt, pass auf, du musst folgende Standardscheine machen für die verschiedenen Sparten und mach wie irgendwie. Ich kann auch...
Fernuniversitäten gehen da ja schon so ein wenig in diese Richtung.
Gut da hatte man ganz viele Bücher zu Hause, die waren auch nicht schön gedruckt. Ich habe mal versucht, Volkswirtschaftslehre in Hagen zu studieren, da habe ich es dann doch lieber so ein bisschen anders gemacht. Aber ich denke, das ist jetzt also lange her. Wenn man das jetzt so mit dem vollen Internet macht, kann man da bestimmt wunderbare Sachen machen. Man kann ja dann auch so über Skype sich auch beraten lassen oder so was. Man kann das ja auch untermischen das Persönliche usw. Und natürlich sind jetzt alle möglichen neuen Lehrformen im Grunde denkbar, auch Organisationen. Also dass ich sagen wir mal bei Harvard die Kurse umsonst nehme, die dann vielleicht so sehr gut sind, die sind ja im Netz und dann mache ich einen Schein, aber an einer deutschen Uni. Also ich gehe dann zum Prüfungsamt hier in Deutschland in Berlin und melde mich bei einer mündlichen Prüfung an und der prüft mich dann auf diesen Harvardstoff, könnte man im Grunde machen.
Und das kommt demnächst. Also praktisch, das kann noch lange dauern, das hat was damit zu tun, dass die Scheine ja was gelten müssen, dass der Stempel darauf was gilt und da kann man mit Juristen noch lange dran rummachen, aber im Grunde, man sieht, dass sofort wie Directbanking oder Amazon oder Ebay einfach so seine 10-12 Jahre braucht und dann ist es durch.
Und jetzt sind wir bei den 10-12 Jahren, die es braucht, um sozusagen auch aus der Universität so eine ferndienstleistbare Tätigkeit zu machen?
Ist schwer zu sagen, wo das genau hinkommt. Weil es natürlich immer noch Kinder gibt, die so diesen persönlichen Kontakt brauchen. Im Grunde müsste man ganz neu nachdenken. Also welche Art von Menschen brauche ich eigentlich in 10 Jahren. Das habe ich versucht, verschiedentlich zu beantworten. Also der Mensch der Zukunft ist ein Mensch, der einen Mehrwert gegenüber dem Internet hat, würde ich sagen. Also der irgendwas kann, was ein Computer nicht automatisch kann. Da gibt es eine Reihe von Berufen, so wie Müllmenschen, wo es körperlich ist, das kann der Computer nicht. Und wenn es was geistiges ist, dann hat das damit zu tun, dass was der Computer nicht kann eigentlich Projekt leiten ist, Leute auf die gleiche Linie zu bringen, vernünftig ein Team zu schaffen, Menschen zu motivieren, dass sie was machen.
Kreativ zu sein.
Kreativ zu sein, Konflikte zu lösen, verschiedene Welten zusammenbringen. Auch so den Willen zu haben, dass man es jetzt auch hinkriegt, also Siegeswillen und so auf die Straße zu bringen. Und das sind so, man muss auch verkaufen können, überzeugen können, gut Storytelling und so weiter können. Also auch ein bisschen werben für sich selber, vernünftig reden. Und das sind Dinge, die in unserem Erziehungssystem eigentlich nicht vorkommen. Also wenn man Glück hat, also meinen Kindern kann ich das beibringen, weil ich ja ein paar Bücher drüber geschrieben habe, kann ich wenigstens das so erklären zu Hause. Aber wenn man das jetzt nicht zu Hause mitkriegt, also jetzt so bildungsfern aufwächst, sagen wir mal, dann hat man überhaupt keine Chance. Also dann geht man durch den Kindergarten durch bis zum Gymnasium, eigentlich bis zum Doktor und hat noch nie verkauft, überzeugt, was kreativ gemacht, es wird ja eher immer noch verschulter, als es früher war.
Also früher hatten wir ja durchschnittliche Studiendauern von 13-14 Semestern glaube ich, war so das Durchschnittsding. Die guten Leute haben alle so nach 12-13 Semestern Diplom gemacht, die anderen dann eher 20 so. So in dem Dreh und da hatte man auch ziemlich viel Zeit, so ein bisschen Erfahrungen mit der Welt zu machen. Das ist alles weggeschmilzt worden, aber vieles davon braucht man. Ich will nicht sagen, dass man jetzt wieder zu einer Trödelzeit von früher zurückgehen müsste, und sagt, ich brauche einfach ein paar Jahre für Persönlichkeitsentfaltung, ich will nur sagen, irgendwo muss das mal auf den Lehrplan. Und da ist es nicht. Da könnte man natürlich drüber nachdenken, dass das reine Faktenlernen, also welche Atome es gibt und wie viele Elektronen Eisen und so hat. Dass man diese Dinge mehr ins Internet legt und von begnadeten Fachexperten erklären lassen und dass die Lehrer mehr so eine Art Vorbilder sind und die menschlichen Qualitäten höher bringen.
Sich sozusagen wirklich um diesen expliziten Mehrwert kümmern und nicht so die Basis.
Diese Idee gibt es ja schon immer, jetzt bei Steiner, bei den Montessori Schulen, bei den Waldorfschulen und so weiter.
Gibt es welche Idee?
Dass man mehr die Menschen in den Vordergrund stellt und sagt, also praktisch das rein lehrerische machen wir dann so ein Jahr vorm Abitur und trainieren die Leute, dass sie bei der bundesweiten Abiturprüfung trotzdem nicht durchfallen. Aber im Prinzip geht es diesen alternativen Schulen mehr um die Persönlichkeit. Und das ist mehr so...
Werden dann auch mehr auf Kosten der Grundausbildung.
Ich will nichts böses sagen, aber ich meine diese Schulen sind mehr so aus Menschenliebe, so aus der weichen humanistischen Theorien gekommen oder Geisteshaltung, nicht Theorien, gekommen und die wollten einfach gute Menschen machen. Und jetzt muss man das aus einem anderen Grund, also praktisch jetzt brauchen wir solche Menschen, die müssen jetzt nicht genau die selben Charakterhaltungen haben, wie man jetzt so bei den humanistischen Schulen hat, aber das normale Business verlangt jetzt, nicht gerade diesen Gutmenschen, aber doch einen, der mit den Leuten klar kommt und vernünftig erklären kann und Konflikte löst oder so was, das ist gar nicht so weit weg. Und diese Schulen sozusagen, die sich um die Persönlichkeit kümmern, gibt es ja schon immer. Also seit Rudolf Steiner mindestens.
Ja.
Und könnten jetzt eher so eine Art nicht Vorbild sein, man muss sozusagen diesen Fokus auf Persönlichkeit vielleicht anders legen in einer gewissen Weise, da kann man drüber reden, aber man eben viel mehr auf die Persönlichkeit legen.
Ist das wirklich was neues? Ich meine, sind diese Fähigkeiten nicht schon immer eigentlich sehr wertvoll gewesen?
Ich habe ein Argument dafür. Wenn man normal in eine Firma gekommen ist, auch bei IBM, dann kriegte man ein Büro zugewiesen mit drei anderen und dann hat man erst mal 5-10 Jahre mit denen zusammen gearbeitet. Und dann hat man sich an die Köppe gekriegt, gestritten und so weiter und man hat sich dran gewöhnt. Also der eine wäscht sich da nur alle drei Wochen die Haare und das stört mich und so weiter und dann kann man das alles 10 Jahre in Ruhe alles auskaspern. Weil man sich daran gewöhnt. Man ist irgendwo so eingesperrt mit den anderen, also für lange Zeit. Also wenn Sie jetzt im Finanzamt arbeiten oder in der Post, dann ist man immer mit diesen Leuten zusammen und dann irgendwann renkt sich das ein. Jetzt ist es so bei vielen Projekten, die man hat, ist die Arbeit irgendwie anders geworden, ist mehr wie bei einem Filmteam. Also praktisch die beschließen, dass sie jetzt irgendwelche 20-2000 Leute fahren in die Karibik, drehen für vier Wochen einen Film und kommen wieder nach Hause oder gehen dann zu einem anderen Platz.
Und man hat im Grunde fast nur einen Tag Zeit, mit den anderen klarzukommen, also das ist alles ganz stark getaktet und bei diesen Projekten, also wenn ich jetzt als Berater zu verschiedenen Firmen gehe, dann komme ich da ja für vier Wochen rein mit meiner Fachkenntnis, mach das, und dann kommt ein anderer und macht das irgendwie mit seiner Fachkenntnis fertig. Dann springe ich praktisch für ein paar Wochen da rein und dann muss ich sozusagen sofort teamfähig sein mit Leuten, die ich noch nie gesehen habe und die werde ich auch nicht wieder sehen. Muss nicht sein, kann sein, dass ich die nie wieder sehe, weil für diesen Kunden ist es dann fertig und dann geht man zu einem anderen Kunden. Und dann ist man so was wie, wie soll man das sagen, so Wanderer zwischen vielen verschiedenen Welten und muss dann sofort klarkommen.
Man ist sozial viel mehr gefordert.
Und diese Fähigkeit ist in dieser Form noch nie wichtig gewesen. Also ich erinnere mich, wir haben im Jahr so 93/94/95 haben wir das erste mal eine Lösung gemacht für eine Spedition in Frankfurt und da musste man dann die Lastwagen dann mit unseren Programmen tatsächlich fahren lassen. Also so die Rundtouren. Also so richtig, dann wenn einer einen Zettel aus dem Drucker geht und dann sagt, dieser Lastwagen wird mit diesem Teil beladen und du fährst jetzt los. Und dann musste jemand von unserer Abteilung acht Wochen oder so was glaube ich nachts in Frankfurt arbeiten, weil natürlich die Lastwagen immer 2 Uhr morgens losfahren, also die kriegen dann Aufträge über den Tag, das wird dann kommissioniert, irgendwie gepackt, wer was auflädt und dann muss man da an eine bestimmte Rampe gehen und dann wird das aufgeladen und dann fahren die morgens los.
Und dann muss so ein Mathematiker plötzlich acht Wochen in der Nacht arbeiten. Und da habe ich ja noch gedacht, der ist Abteilungsleiter und ich habe zu Hause gesessen, sag zu meiner Frau, kann man ihm das zumuten? Also praktisch normal war, so Wissenschaftler arbeitet jetzt immer von 9-17 oder 18 Uhr oder so oder hat so einen geregelten Arbeitstag und jetzt muss der acht Wochen dahin, was sagt seine Frau dazu oder das war so der Beginn dieser Reisetätigkeit. Also dass sozusagen der Arbeitsplatz plötzlich zerfleddert, das war eine ganz einschneidende Erfahrung. Und da haben wir uns noch gedacht, können wir dem das zumuten? Das hat ihm sogar Spaß gemacht, das ist nicht schlimm gewesen. Er hat dann aber, ich glaube der ist auch dann gegen eine Leitplanke gefahren, weil er 3 Uhr nachts völlig übermüdet war und dann hat natürlich die Firma das bezahlt und wir haben gesagt, das ist ???
Und dann haben wir gesagt, das ist schwierig mit dem Arbeitsrecht, war das überhaupt erlaubt, dass er da abends noch arbeitet und hätten wir das richtig beantragt und so, und da kriegen wir alle einen roten Kopf, ist nichts passiert, nur richtige Schramme im Auto, und da dämmerte mir, das erinnere ich noch so, dass jetzt plötzlich die Arbeit von den Leuten in IBM sich auflöst, die ist nicht mehr im Büro, sondern so Art als Fachexperte dann irgendwie mal da mal da. Und dann heute hat man das viel exzessiver, da gibt es dann eben Kollegen, die sind ein Jahr bei Nokia in Helsinki und dann bei Ford in London und reisen so rum. Dann sieht man die Berater, dass sie Montagmorgen um 6 Uhr den ersten Flug nach London nehmen und kommen dann Freitagabend wieder. Versuchen dann family zu machen übers Wochenende.
Ja es gibt ja auch diesen starken Trend, immer selbstständiger zu werden. Sehr viele entscheiden sich ja auch schon gegen Firmenkonstrukte oder sind halt einfach freier Berater.
Ja da mag man das. Also ich habe ja jetzt als Keynotespeaker praktisch einen völlig wilden Job, also die Hälfte der Zeit bin ich einfach normal zu Hause und die andere Hälfte bin ich total auf Achse. Also das was ich damals als Schreckensbild aller Zeiten gesehen habe. Dass man immerzu weg ist, das ist ja jetzt mein Alltag, das hätte ich damals nicht verstehen können. Also wenn man mir gesagt hätte, du musst das jetzt machen, hätte ich gesagt, das tue ich auf keinen Fall. Ich will jetzt jeden Tag um 17 Uhr zu Hause sein oder 18 Uhr. Und das Erstaunliche ist jetzt irgendwie auch, dass ich selbstständig bin, wenn bei mir jetzt einer angerufen hätte bei IBM als Angestellter, du musst morgen Nacht noch irgendwie einen Vortrag halten in London oder was. Da hätte ich gesagt, mach ich nicht, das ist mir zu stressig. Wenn man jetzt Freiberufler ist, dann weiß man, dass das ein Arbeitsauftrag ist und dass das gut ist, und man verdient damit Geld.
Und man sieht plötzlich Arbeit auch anders. Also als Selbstständiger sehe ich plötzlich, dass Arbeit auch gut ist, weil die mich ja ernährt. Und wenn man Angestellter ist und jemand kommt dann mit so einer ätzenden Arbeit, die man nicht gern macht, dann sagt man, bleib mir vom Hals. Dann ist man eher ärgerlich und so weiter. Und wenn ich mir – ich hätte das nicht geglaubt, also wenn mir einer gesagt hätte, wie mein Leben in 10 Jahren aussieht, damals als wir so feste Büros hatten, hätte ich gesagt, nein das kann keiner wollen.
Ja und diesen Prozess macht glaube ich jetzt irgendwie ein Großteil der Menschheit auch nach. Also weil IBM natürlich sehr sehr weit vorn ist mit der Arbeitsorganisation. Und ich habe dann gar nicht so viel Mühe gehabt, die Zukunft vorherzusagen, weil die IBM im Grunde 4/5/10 Jahre vorher schon so ist. Und dann kommen die anderen Leute und sagen, Gunter Dück das stimmt nicht was du sagst, so wird es nie kommen und dann sage ich, bei uns ist das schon so seit 5 Jahren. Und dann kann natürlich, wenn man so an diesen vordersten Frontfirmen ist, relativ schneller abschätzen, wie so die Arbeitswelt dann insgesamt konvergiert.
So schlimm ist es gar nicht oder?
Also wir stellen fest, durch Veränderung der Mobilität der Leute insgesamt. Aber eben auch der schnelleren Kommunikation, die dann wiederum ja ganz neue Projektkonstellationen ermöglicht, spielt eigentlich so diese althergebrachte Firmenstruktur sicherlich noch eine Rolle, aber nicht mehr in dem selben Maße, zumindest ist es nicht das einzige, wo auch ein Bildungssystem hindenken muss. Ich glaube, früher gab es sehr stark diese Prägung von, Leute, die jetzt hier durch den Universitätsprozess oder jeglichen Ausbildungsprozess, fängt ja schon bei der Schule an, durchgehen, die müssen wir so hier mit dem Standardrüstzeug ausstatten und irgendwann kommt dann die Ausbildung und dann hast du dein Beruf und dann bist du das bis an dein Lebensende und das ist halt jetzt aus vielen Gründen nicht mehr so.
Wenn man jetzt schaut, wie manche Bildungsinstitutionen und wir hatten da ja schon drüber gesprochen, mit den Möglichkeiten des Netzes umgeht, wie zum Beispiel – was war das Beispiel? - Harvard, andere Universitäten in den USA machen es ja ähnlich, man findet komplette Vorlesungen, detailliert und in weiten Teilen auch sehr gut präsentierte Inhalte, wo man sich im Prinzip wirklich nur noch vor den Rechner setzen muss und das komplette Studium absolvieren kann, also zumindest alle Vorlesungen so haben kann. Die Buchmittel etc. Sonstigen Informationen sind ja genauso vorhanden. Also ich könnte im Prinzip gleichwertig den Stoff konsumieren. Warum kommt das alles aus den USA? Warum kommt das nicht aus Deutschland? Wo sind denn die Universitäten, die das hier machen? Und warum machen die das nicht? Haben Sie da irgendeine Ahnung? Gibt es einen guten Grund?
Na gut, im Grunde müsste man das wichtig finden, dass man lehrt.
Ja.
Ja dann müsste man vielleicht irgendeine Fakultät vielleicht mal einschrumpfen oder ein paar Stellen frei machen für so Filmteams. Muss sich ja an anderer Stelle dann Mühe geben. Ich kann ja jetzt nicht einfach so ein Mikrofon da rein stellen, das wird ja dann auch keine richtig gute Vorlesung und das ist dann echte Arbeit. Also eine richtig super super Vorlesung zu machen, dass es sich dann lohnt, die auch zu filmen, kostet ja richtig richtig viel Arbeit. Ich nehme an, 5 mal mehr als normal eine zu halten, die man so aus der Schublade zieht.
Aber was ist denn die Motivation für amerikanischen Universitäten, das zumindest teilweise so zu machen? Ist das Werbung?
Ich denke schon.
Ausschließlich? Ich meine im Prinzip kommen doch da sicherlich auch Leute, die sagen, aber wenn wir das so machen, warum soll dann noch einer zu uns kommen?
Also ich kenne jetzt, wir haben einen Teil der Familien in Amerika, das gilt nicht, wenn man die Prüfung...
Wenn man nicht da war. Nein die machen ja wie wahnsinnig Aufnahmeprüfungen bei allen möglichen Unis und die gehen auf die teuerste, die sie sich leisten können, auf die man gerade noch angenommen wird. Also praktisch es gibt zwei Limitationen, wie viel Geld man hat und wie hoch jemand angenommen wird von einer Universität. Also man probiert jetzt in Harvard angenommen zu werden, das werden nur wenige, kriegt man eine Ablehnung, dann ist man stolz, dass man von Nummer 21 angenommen wird in einem Ranking und wenn die Eltern das bezahlen, dann geht man da hin. Und da sagen sie, die amerikanischen Unis haben das irgendwie so hingekriegt, dass das sehr wichtig ist. Also für die Leute ist es sehr wichtig, bei einer guten Uni gewesen zu sein.
Wenn man nicht da war?
Ja.
Und jetzt einfach die Kurse im Internet zu nehmen ginge, aber das wäre nicht so das richtige. Also praktisch die legen Wert darauf, dass man in einer vernünftigen Uni war, ich glaube die nehmen sich auch sehr viel mehr Zeit, also mit den Leuten zu interagieren.
Ja gut, aber wenn man sich jetzt deren Vorlesungen gibt, war man ja im Prinzip auf der Uni.
Ja aber so sieht man das da nicht. Also praktisch ich ... blödes Beispiel. Also meine Videos sind auch alle im Internet, also Sie können ungefähr alle Reden, die ich gehalten habe, sehen. Also die sind nicht alle drin im Internet, aber ich glaube so 100 Stunden kann man sich antun.
Und die Leute sagen doch immer noch, sie wollen es nochmal persönlich sehen.
Bestimmt ja.
Ja weil das wahrscheinlich eine ganz andere Erfahrungsebene ist an der Stelle.
Ja und dann kann man sagen, also wenn man so ein bisschen schafft so schwach Star zu sein, dann bildet – also bei den besten sozusagen  oder bei den richtig guten – ist es doch noch den Leuten wichtig, persönlich da zu sein. Also ich habe jetzt übermorgen in der Sparkasse in Bad Mergentheim??? muss ich von der Republica gleich weg, das ist schon lange beschlossen. Da sind 500 Leute gekommen, dass ich einen Vortrag über Innovation halten soll in Bad Mergentheim, 500 Leute. Veranstalter ist ganz stolz, dass so viele kommen. Obwohl sie sich natürlich die Rede im Internet angucken könnten. Das wollen sie aber nicht so. Und da gibt es so eine Art, also in meinem Business so was wie Eventbusiness, also dass man das doch so live sehen muss trotzdem. Aber wie gesagt, das können nur ganz wenige.
Also es ist so, dass die Leute dann wirklich das nur bei Harvard noch gut finden. Also die richtig tollen Universitäten, also wenn Sie ein Businessmodell machen wollen, was ganz wunderbares machen, dann ist den Leuten der Liveeindruck doch noch besser als der andere. Also praktisch der Ruhm von Harvard wird immer größer. Sie können alles umsonst ins Internet stellen, das ist nicht der Punkt, aber sozusagen der Nimbus dann live da gewesen zu sein und ausgewählt oder akzeptiert worden zu sein in einem so schwierigen Auswahlverfahren, das gibt einem so viel Ruhm, da strengt man sich noch mehr an als vielleicht vor 20 Jahren.
Soll das denn bei deutschen Universitäten nicht genauso sein? Schulterzucken.
Ich würde das tun, also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie was damit zu tun hätte, würde ich dafür stark plädieren, also die besten Unis könnten das ja locker einfach mitmachen.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich kenne das jetzt, weil wir ja so Reorganisation mitgemacht haben. Ich habe ja jetzt so mathematisch welche gemacht und dann müsste man natürlich irgendwo, wenn man das gut macht, einfach bei einer Universität sagen, welche von den Professoren echt vernünftig gute Vorlesungen halten können. Das sind dann vielleicht nur 10% und die muss man dann echt mit Namen an die Wand schreiben.
Das sind aber so Prozesse im Menschsein, die sind sehr schwierig. Also dann sagen, der Kollege und so und dann fangen sie alle an, eifersüchtig zu werden und so was und das muss man einfach normal managen. Man muss auch als sagen wir mal als Universitätspräsident dann irgendwie so wie sich ??? Leute aus Spanien holt, holt man dann eben bestimmte Professoren, die wunderbar auf bestimmten Gebieten sind, dass man ein vollständiges Team hat. Also da muss man sich ja dann auch für Lehre, sozusagen wenn man jetzt eine ??? hat, sich ein vernünftiges Team zusammen kaufen.
Ja.
Was ja eigentlich sowieso der Fall sein sollte.
Ja jetzt besorgen sie sich halt immer nur möglichst gute Professoren. Aber es ist nicht so eine Anstrengung sozusagen, dass man in der Lehre beliebig gut besetzt wäre, das wäre eine andere Berufungspolitik. Das hat gar keine Chance bei den jetzigen Systemen, gar keine.
Und warum nicht?
Ja weil es nach den Publikationspunkten geht.
Ja aber sollte es danach gehen?
Da müsste man einfach sagen, wofür eine Uni gut ist. Also da muss man wahrscheinlich die ganzen Grundsatzfragen nochmal neu stellen. Weil welche Art Erziehung wollen wir bieten? Was soll ein Mensch da können?
Genau.
Und im Grunde hat man die Bildung als solche nicht richtig besprochen. Man hat irgendwo der Industrie nachgegeben, die haben gesagt, die wollen nicht irgendwelche Leute mit 13 Semestern Diplom haben, sondern mit 6 Semestern Bachelor, das tut es. Jetzt im Augenblick stehen öfter mal so vorne auf der Süddeutschen Zeitung Seite 1 steht drin, eigentlich wollen sie nicht so wirklich Bachelor, sondern sie wollen so Menschen, die managen, verkaufen, erzählen.
Nein nicht Erfahrung, die als Persönlichkeit was bringen. Also es war jetzt wieder die Rede von, das war vorne auf der Süddeutschen, sie haben so testweise Personalern Zeugnisse gegeben und die Personaler haben dann gar nicht so sehr die besten Noten gegeben, was man immer denkt, also dass sie die Einser raus suchen, sondern sie haben die rausgesucht, wo aus den Kopfnoten rausging, dass das vernünftige Menschen sind. Denn Leute mit zweifelhaften Betragensnoten, aber sonst ganz guten Noten haben sie dann eher gescheut. Wenn dann sind sie mehr, also praktisch die Personaler versuchen eigentlich eher jetzt schon, dieses persönliche höher zu bewerten, als die eigentlichen Zensuren.
Erfahrung haben.
Das ist gar nicht so klar. Die Personaler richten sich jetzt schon langsam nach der neuen Welt, aber den Studenten ist das nicht klar. Ich kriege dauernd immer so Welthass-Emails von der Form, du ich habe überall 1,0 und sie nehmen mich nicht. Und da muss man sagen, pass mal auf, da ist irgendwie ein Problem mit dir. Und ich habe mal so hin und her geschossen und habe gesagt, dann schicke mir mal deine Bewerbung, dann gucken wir mal, ob ich die überhaupt gleich in den Papierkorb schmeißen würde. Und dann stehen da diese ....
Haben die gemacht?
Ja, und dann sind das meistens so abgeschriebene Bewerbungen aus dem Internet. Also praktisch, ich bin bereit, mich für jeden Zweck der Firma also...
Untertan zu machen.
Ganz schnell in neue Zusammenhänge einzulesen.
Bin flexibel.
Ich bin flexibel.
Anpassungsfähig.
Und dann sage ich, pass mal auf, das sagt zu mir, also wenn ich Chef bin und einstellen soll, dann sagt das, du kannst eigentlich nichts, aber du bist willig. Aber das ist eine reine Behauptung, weil woran sehe ich, dass du wirklich flexibel bist.
Ja das klingt vor allem auch für mich so ein bisschen wie, ich habe nichts mit einzubringen.
Das ist aber klar, ich habe das ja jetzt mit meinem Sohn gemacht. Er hat geguckt, was schreiben wir in die Bewerbung und dann steht da eigentlich, er hat jetzt ein ganz super super Mathedoktor, aber mehr nicht. Also es gibt nur eine Zeile her, super in Mathe. Und dann sagt er, ja was schreiben wir jetzt. Dann sage ich, du schreibst einfach, ich habe einen super Mathedoktor und bewerbe mich jetzt bei Ihnen als Berufsanfänger Punkt. Dann sagt er, ja das kannst du nicht sagen. Ich sage, ja bist du aber doch. Dann sagt er, ja und dann nehmen die mich? Ich sage, das ist doch nicht um die Sache rumgeschwätzt. Du kannst jetzt noch eine Seite dazu schreiben, aber das merkt doch sowieso jeder.
Und da haben wir eben immer zu Hause so Diskussionen. Wir haben viele kommen aus dem Dorf mal und sagen, kannst du mal über die Bewerbung drüber gucken. Und sie haben den Mut nicht, einfach zu schreiben, …
Ich fang an.
Ja. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm. Jetzt …
Das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen so eine Angst. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt einfach so ein Problem der Mehrheit ist. Mich hat das selber auch immer so ein bisschen gestört, dass man nicht bereit ist, aus der Masse hervorzustechen. Dass man es sozusagen als Malus empfindet, wenn man irgendwie besondere Eigenschaften hat. Man will erst mal sich anpassen, man will erst mal die Eigenschaften, die gefordert sind und damit sozusagen ja, womit man sich dann ja überhaupt nicht mehr unterscheidet von allen anderen.
Bei Google war eine Bewerbung. Da muss man aufschreiben, was man für Hobbys hat, weil Google da Wert drauf legt. Sag ich, ja guck mal Fußball. Spielt Fußball. Ich sage, komm es hilft doch nichts, das ist doch dein, schreib Fußball. Kommt von Google, das ist toll. Ich habe mal mit irgendwem...
Also von Google der Suchmaschine oder von Google das Unternehmen?
Unternehmen. Und sage ich, und ihr findet Fußball toll? Sage ich, wenn ich eine Bewerbung lese ist Dr. Dr. So super Statistik irgendwie so abgehoben und dann denkt man doch, der ist irgendwie sehr schüchtern oder das ist vielleicht eine schwierige Geburt. Da müssen wir den lange angucken, aber wenn er Fußball spielt, ist doch nicht schlimm. Und die Leute wollen einfach nur normale Menschen mit echten Zweifeln.
Schwächen.
Nicht Schwächen, einfach zwei Füße auf den Boden.
Aber auch mit Schwächen.
Na die haben die natürlich klar. Und diese Bewerbungsschreiben sind dann irgendwie völlig synthetisch. Also die schlimmsten, das ist neu jetzt irgendwie, das muss irgendwie in einem Buch stehen, so weil ich eine 1 in BWL und weil ich und weil und weil und weil, bin ich jetzt sehr sicher, eine wichtige Bereicherung für Ihre Firma darstellen zu können. Das ist schön oder?
Ach furchtbar. Buzzword.
Habe ich ein paar Mal gesehen.
Ja.
Und dann sage ich, Leute könnt ihr das mal lassen? Ich bin doch der, der euch einstellt, und dann beurteile ich, ob ihr eine Bereicherung für meine Abteilung seid, das ist jetzt ein bisschen arrogant, die Bewertung vorwegzunehmen. Dann sagen die, ja aber es ist besser, ich sage es schon mal.
Ist schon sehr aufdringlich. Ich finde ja schon die unterwürfige Variante bisschen zweifelhaft.
Es gibt auch so eine arrogante Variante. So ungefähr, ich habe alle Punkte gemacht, die laut Bewerbungsführer von der FAZ nötig sind, und deswegen habe ich jetzt das Recht, eine Einstellung zu haben. Ich habe auch so eine bekommen, hallo Herr Dück – das war die schönste – ich habe jetzt drei Semesterferien mich rumgeschlagen und Geld verdient, einmal mit Betten bauen, einmal mit Kellnern und einmal mit Müll ausleeren und jetzt so in Vordiplomnähe denke ich doch, dass es an die Zeit gekommen ist, mal was wertvolles zu arbeiten und bitte Sie deshalb in der IBM nach einer vernünftigen Stelle für mich zu suchen.
Oh Mann.
Nein und das sind dann Leute, die sagen, ich wunder mich, warum ich nicht genommen werde. Und ich habe wie gesagt öfter mal so rein geguckt in Leute, die so ein bisschen verzweifelt waren, das kann man zum Teil klären. Und dann sagen sie ja, sozusagen schreib es doch normal auf. Und dann sagen sie, ja aber.
Wieder dahin kommen, zu überlegen, was kann sozusagen dagegen getan werden? Also ich deute das mal so als Dividualität??? fördern oder einfach?
Man kann sich ja ein bisschen auch interessieren und Praktika machen, um was zu lernen. Also praktisch ist es oft so, man kann ja Praktika in Firmen machen, so auch als Schüler auch in den Ferien mal. Da muss man sehr aufpassen, weil manchmal wollen die Leute, die einfach nur so im Büro helfen und irgendwie ein Haufen Zeug kopieren. Muss man sich wirklich Mühe geben. Man kann ja meinetwegen umsonst arbeiten, aber sagen, ich mache irgendwas wirklich richtig mit und bringe mich ein und arbeite richtig schöne Sachen. Also mein Sohn hat mal vier Wochen in Heidelberg bei einer Firma eine ganze Messe mitgestaltet. Also mit Plakat drucken und alles, Design machen, welche Kugelschreiben werden denn verschenkt usw. Und hat dann so 6-8 Wochen mal so den ganzen Ablauf kennengelernt und das hat so richtig Spaß gemacht, dass er das auch gut kann.
Da muss man halt so ein bisschen suchen, dass man so eine Stelle kriegt, wo man nicht so als Hilfsarbeiter mit dabei ist. Da hat es einen – weiß ich noch – einen wunderbaren Moment in meinem Leben gegeben, da ist der Bote gekommen, ein Bote von der Druckerei, in der Mittagspause in die Firma, hat das Plakat aufgerollt und hat gesagt, ist es so gut, zu meinem Sohn, der war ja wirklich nur Praktikant für acht Wochen. Mein Sohn hat gesagt, ja finden Sie nicht, dass der Balken, der Winkel ein bisschen tiefer sein müsste? Sagt er, ja wo Sie das jetzt sagen, das könnte sein. Und dann sagt mein Sohn, das fand ich gut. Also nach acht Wochen Beruf. Und sagt er, und wie viel kostet das, wenn man das jetzt anständig machen?
Sagt der Drucker, ja 250 Euro oder irgendwas, wird es wohl machen, das zu ändern. Da hat mein Sohn gesagt, dann würde ich sagen, Sie machen das mal. Dann ist der weggegangen und kam er nach Hause, darf man das als Praktikant eigentlich? Dann habe ich ihn in den Arm genommen, ich habe mich so gefreut, habe gesagt, aus dir wird mal ein vernünftiger Arbeiter, war einfach eine vernünftige Entscheidung. Und dann finden das so, das muss man ja irgendwie hinkriegen.
Verantwortung übernehmen.
Jetzt einfach sagen, ich bin verantwortlich und ich habe jetzt die ganze Messe gemacht und jetzt soll es an diesen paar Cent auch nicht scheitern. Also er hat ja dann auch gesagt, meinst du morgen werden die mir den Kopf abhacken. Ich habe gesagt, kann sein, dass die das tun, aber ich finde dich gut.
Ja. Das ist wichtig, dass man auch nicht an so einem Obrigkeitswahn leidet. Ich frage mich halt jetzt immer wieder, was ist jetzt sozusagen die Botschaft, aus dem was wir jetzt gerade so diskutierend betrachten. Gerade für das Bildungssystem auf der einen Seite, aber auch eben für das Selbstverständnis der Leute, die in dieses Bildungssystem gehen. Denn ich denke, man kann ja eigentlich auch mit der richtigen Grundhaltung. Ist ja nicht so, ja die Uni ist jetzt so oder so oder das Bildungssystem ist so, oder die Gesellschaft ist. Das hat ja auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, mit welcher Erwartung man selber da reingeht, mit welcher Grundhaltung man sich dem System gegenüberstellt.
Man muss ja irgendwie die Verantwortung langsam für das eigene Leben übernehmen, das ist immer viel stärker. Also weil man wie gesagt früher in so einem Büro gesessen hat mit vielen und der Chef war immer derselbe und dann kriegt man natürlich die Verantwortung übertragen, das machst du, das machst du, das machst du. Wenn man jetzt einfach in wechselnden Stellen arbeitet oder in anderen Teamst, oder auch an anderen Universitäten in einer Forscherlaufbahn, da wechselt man ja heute öfter mal so die Unis, was früher auch nicht so war, da muss man sehr viel mehr Selbstverantwortung übernehmen, auch Selbstdisziplin haben und sein Leben selber in die Hand nehmen. Das sagt nicht mehr so oft jemand, was man zu tun hat. Das ist das Problem. Man kriegt auch nicht mehr so viel Feedback. Also viele Leute erleben jetzt so im Geschäftsleben, dass man eigentlich nur die Zahlen hat. Also ich habe meine Verkaufszahlen oder meine Umsatzzahlen, also so wie das nackte Business gibt mir ein Ergebnis, aber man kriegt nicht so viel Coaching mehr.
Also früher kriegte man auch kein Coaching, aber man wurde ausgeschimpft wenigstens, wenn was falsch war. Dann kriegt man Druck.
Negatives Coaching.
Ja dieses negative Coaching. Das hätte ich besser und blablabla und heute ist das negative Coaching eigentlich in ein Zahlen drin. Weil wenn man misst macht sind die Zahlen nicht so gut und dann kriegt man sozusagen sehr anonym von einer Excel-Tablette eine Watsche. Und ich glaube, man muss mehr eine Bildungsszene aufbringen oder eine Bildung und eine Führung im Unternehmen aufstellen, die sich mehr wieder über diese positiven Coachings hält. Also dass man Leute wirklich ausbildet. Also so per Hand trainiert. Ich wundere mich, dass man...
Wir reden jetzt sozusagen sowohl eigentlich über eine Ausbildung innerhalb eines Unternehmens als auch an der Universität.
Ja aber ich meine, wenn meine Kinder, wenn man jetzt so in der Musikschule war, also meine Tochter hat Querflöte lange betrieben. Mein Sohn Fußball und da sieht man, dass man da persönliches Coaching bekommt. Das ist völlig klar, wenn man als 8-Jähriger Fußball spielt, dann nimmt der den einen und sagt an der Seitenlinie, du machst das und das und das. Da kriegt man also in Sport und Kunst kriegt man dieses Coaching schon, also das ist völlig klar. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum man, so was wie Verkaufen lernen, Führen lernen, Managen lernen, Projekte lernen oder so da kriegt man eigentlich nichts. Also da kriegt man so einen Kurs. Also ein Projekt hat ein Anfang und ein Ende und zwischendurch musst du Buchführung machen so ungefähr. Man kriegt so die Konventionen dieses ganzen Ablaufes in den Kopf geknallt und die Paragraphen, aber es ist niemand da, der sich so Mühe macht, einmal so bei der Arbeit zu begleiten und zu sagen, das so und so und so hätte er das gern.
Und in Ihrer wissenschaftlichen Ausbildung, war das im Prinzip das selbe?
Ja.
Niemand kam und hat einem gesagt, geh so und so mit den Studenten um oder was fehlt da?
Da müsste man mehr diskutieren, ich habe das bei meinem Doktorvater irgendwie ein bisschen mit reingekriegt. Also ich habe Glück gehabt, so gut gecoacht zu werden, also nicht gecoacht hat er, aber wir haben, ich bin so quasi aufgewachsen im Statistikinstitut in Göttingen. Es war nicht die Mathefakultät, also der Fachbereich, sondern das war ein eigenes Gebäude mit 1,5 Lehrstühlen so was. Professor Ulrich Krengel???, der da Statistik gemacht hat und da haben die Leute ab Vordiplom irgendwo gelebt. Also da war ein Leseraum, wir haben viel Schach, Blitzschach gespielt und die Professoren haben da in der Mittagspause wild diskutiert und Kaffee gab es immer umsonst, den haben irgendwie die Professoren bezahlt.
Und die Studenten konnten auch reinkommen, auch Mittagessen gehen mit denen usw. Und ich habe irgendwie mitten zwischen diesen Leuten da mein Leben nach dem Vordiplom verbracht und das war toll. Ich habe versucht, dann viele Elemente dann irgendwo auch jetzt dann in mein Abteilungsleiterdasein zu bringen. Also dass man viel viel spricht mit den Leuten. Und es ist dann so, dass ein Teil der Mitarbeiter eigentlich immer sagt, bleib mir vom Hals, du willst schon wieder mit mir herummeckern, die sind ein bisschen verloren. Also man muss es irgendwie hinkriegen, dass Mitarbeiter sagen, kannst du mal was zu irgendwas gestern zu der Präsentation sagen? Sondern das und das war gut und das war schlecht und dann sagen sie, ist gut. Manche wollen wissen, also gecoacht werden, im Sinne von trainiert und manche haben da Angst vor. Also die wollen eigentlich nur gelobt werden.
Haben Angst, dass sie irgendwie einen drauf kriegen oder so was, die sind empfindlich. Und das müsste man den Leuten raus erziehen. Also praktisch man merkt immer noch, dass es viele Menschen, viele Schüler, viele Mitarbeiter gibt, die nicht offen sind, also die wollen gar nicht gecoacht werden, selbst wenn man käme und würde so einen Ansatz machen. Dann habe ich immer so einen Spruch, meinen Lieblingsspruch habe ich gefunden in einer Moschee in Schwetzingen gibt es im Garten so eine Moschee, die ist nicht richtig Islam, sondern so als Schmuck sozusagen da. Da steht da oben so ein Spruch drin, der Tor hält Rat für Feindschaft. Es ist dumm, sozusagen, doofe Leute halten Ratschläge für Feindschaft. Und da muss man lange lange üben, also wenn man Leute coacht.
Weil viele Leute, wenn man sagt, du sollst das und das mal anders machen, besser machen oder probiere das, dann sagen sie, aha du willst mir die Gehaltserhöhung stehen. Das ist eine Vorbereitung, ich weiß, dass ihr alle gegen mich seid, und dann geht das wieder los. Und das sieht man am Gesicht, also die sagen das nicht, sondern da fällt irgendwie der Vorhang und sagt, jetzt will er nur auf mir rumhacken. Und ich glaube ganz ganz wichtig ist für die Bildung der Zukunft ist, dass man in diesem Sinne offen ist und wenn Leute kommen und sagen, warum machst du das nicht so, dann muss man einfach froh sein, dass man das mit ihnen diskutieren kann und dass man was lernen kann. Es kann auch sein, dass die anderen  Unrecht haben, aber man kriegt wenigstens mal ein Feedback.
Kritikfähigkeit lehren sozusagen.
Ja einfach Offenheit, muss ja gar nicht Kritik sein.
Aber es hat ja auch was mit Ängsten zu tun. Ich meine Leute sind ja wahrscheinlich auch deshalb in ihrer Kritikfähigkeit eingeschränkt, sage ich mal so salopp, weil sie auf der anderen Seite eben auch Ängste aufgebaut bekommen.
Und man hat noch mehr Kritik, also man hat ich glaube, das ist nicht nur, dass man Kritik einstecken kann, sondern man lernt auch nicht, welche zu geben. Weil also die meisten Leute sagen, man müsste dem mal so den Hintern versohlen, aber ich trau mich nicht, dieses heikle Thema aufzubringen. Also praktisch bei Mitarbeitern, die trauen sich meistens nicht, irgendwas gegen den Chef zu sagen. Dann sagen sie, komm ist egal. Dann sage ich, pass auf, geh hin und hau ihn. Dann sagen sie, ja aber dann gibt es irgendwie einen echten Konflikt. Aber dann sage ich, natürlich gibt es einen echten Konflikt. Aber da muss man doch durch. Dann sagen sie, das trauen sie sich nicht. Und dann wird praktisch von beiden Seiten zurück gezuckt. Also praktisch man weiß...
Alle wissen, dass irgendwie was schief läuft, aber keiner sagt es.
Wenn einer was sagt gibt es sofort einen Konflikt und dann sagen alle Leute, tu das nicht oder so was. Und das ist auch so, ich habe erst gedacht, in Amerika wäre das anders zum Beispiel, da würden die das offener sagen, da ist das aber auch nicht. Also die loben sich ja sehr viel mehr, da wird das …
Da ist immer alles total awesome.
Da sagt man auch nicht so, komm das will ich nicht oder so was.
Wird eher den Deutschen unterstellt, sehr direkt zu sein eigentlich.
Nein, so dass viele Arbeitervertreter oder so auch Betriebsräte zum Beispiel, die ja fast unverletzlich sind, dass die auch nicht sich trauen, zum Boss zu gehen und zu sagen, komm mach das mal. Dann sage ich manchmal, geh doch einfach hin und bring es zur Sprache. Ja dann ist der und der böse. Dann sage ich, so what, das ist deine Aufgabe, du bist Betriebsrat, dafür haben dich die Leute gewählt usw. Und dann geht er zu den Leuten, das ist auch wieder ein Fehler, soll ich das jetzt mal zur Sprache bringen? Und dann sagen die Leute, nein lieber nicht. Ja und so, da wird ziemlich viel unter den Tisch gekehrt. Und ich glaube die bessere Strategie ist, wenn man Chef ist, dass man mit den Mitarbeitern unendlich lange redet, immer eins immer one to one und die solange coacht, das dauert vielleicht ein halbes bis ein ganzes Jahr und dann arbeiten die so irre gut, dass man dann irgendwie fast nichts mehr zu tun hat als Chef.
Man kann sich fast so obsolet machen, das glaube ich fast wohl, dass das an der Schule auch ginge, also wenn man Leute für ein Fach wirklich interessiert, dass die dann von selbst dann lernen und das Internet benutzen und dann hat man es ja geschafft. Man muss im Grunde so eine Art Grundmotivation offenhalten und Begeisterung reinbringen.
Könnte man dann sagen, dass man sozusagen das Bildungssystem auf der einen Seite – jetzt fasse ich mal so ein bisschen mal zusammen, um auch mal langsam zum Ende kommen wollen vielleicht sollten – wir haben über verschiedene Sachen geredet, aber dieses menschliche zu betonen in der Bildung ist wichtig, erfordert aber, wie wir jetzt auch wissen, Zeit, Konzentration auf den einzelnen, lange Gespräche, was aber auch gut ist, weil in dem Moment, wo man diese Zeit auch bekommt, das führt ja auch zu einer – also ist ja nicht nur so, dass man Wissen weitergibt, sondern dass einfach diese Aufmerksamkeit, die man so erhält und nicht nur, dass man nur so ein kleiner Besucher in so einer Vorlesung regelmäßig ist und dann war das sozusagen das Studium. Hat man wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr davon, wenn man irgendwie alle zwei Wochen mal einen Tag der Fokus ist, das hält sehr viel länger vor.
Das heißt wenn man die Lehre was das Zeitkontingent auch der beteiligten Personen, der Lehrer, der Professoren, etc. Des sonstigen Personals daraufhin optimiert, sich mehr die Zeit für diesen menschlichen Coachingteil sage ich mal ganz salopp zu kümmern und vielleicht die Basisausbildung mehr dem Internet zu überlassen. Ja also nicht irgendjemand im Internet, sondern sagen wir mal eine Automatisierung dadurch, dass man einfach Dinge, die sich nicht geändert haben, einfach einmal aufzeichnet und sich daraus erst mal primär ernährt.
Ja gut, vielleicht braucht man auch neben der menschlichen Sache so was wie eine Metadiskussion über die Bildung, also was die Wissenschaft eigentlich ist, was man damit macht, warum man das macht, was wichtige Forschung ist, was nicht so wichtige Forschung ist. Dass manche Theorien sind wunderschön so zusammenhängend, weil das gerade passt, manches in Zahlentheorie ist so sehr aus Jahrtausenden von Sumerern und Babyloniern und Persern zusammengewürfelt, das ist dann ein bisschen zufällig entstanden. Und dann kann man so ein bisschen über Geschichte erzählen, das einordnen, dass man einfach sagt, woher das gekommen ist. Viele Betriebswirtschaftstheorien sind jetzt irgendwie nach vielleicht Kriegen oder nach Erfolgen mit Japan mit Toyota entstanden usw. Die haben alle ihre Historie und dass man sozusagen diese Einbettung und Einordnung des ganzen Stoffes und die historischen Perspektiven und die Wichtigkeit der jetzigen Forschung für irgendwas und die Probleme davon, dass man das mit den wirklich auch bespricht und diskutiert. Und das sind Dinge, die man glaube ich mehr diskutieren muss.
Und wenn ich dann rein runtergehe auf nur Kostentheorie oder Produktionstheorie, das kann man wahrscheinlich im Internet dann besser lernen, aber man muss vorher wissen, wozu das gut ist, wie das mit den anderen verzahnt ist usw. Das lässt sich schwer glaube ich in Filmen wiedergeben.
Ja ich finde es auch interessant, dass Sie jetzt auch die Wissenschaftsgeschichte auch nochmal erwähnen. Wir hatten jetzt hier in dieser Serie in der ersten Folge tatsächlich ein Gespräch mit Anette Vogt, die selbst eben Wissenschaftsgeschichte im Fokus hat und auch da klang das schon raus, dass das eigentlich auch ein Fehler, ein Versäumnis mindestens ist, da nicht genug Wert draufzulegen, eben das Vollständige auch, also die vollständige Geschichte, was heißt vollständige, aber zumindest Wissenschaftsgeschichte als solche auch Teil des Unterrichts stärker zu betonen, einfach um sie selber glaube ich auch besser verorten zu können, um auch besser sich selbst einordnen zu können.
Man muss im Grunde die Gründe verstehen, woher was gekommen ist. Also ich meine...
Das Warum.
So bin ich jetzt nicht total gebildet, aber so bei Humboldt ist es so gewesen, dass man sagt, man hat eine gewisse Allgemeinbildung in den preußischen Schulen, damit die Leute alle, sagen wir mal, Grundregeln verstehen. Also so normal rechnen können, normal schreiben können, die Verkehrsschilder so was lesen können, wenn es welche gab. Also dass sie gewisse gemeinsame Fertigkeit haben. Dass das Volk ein höheres Niveau im Zusammenleben haben kann, weil gewisse Grunddinge jedem bekannt sind. Und da hat man so eine Art Schule draus gemacht und dann Schulpflicht. Das ist ein bisschen gekippt, also ich sage es einfach mal so, was ich verstanden habe, was ich jetzt so ein bisschen gelesen habe, dass in ein 60er Jahren, als ich dran war mit Schüler, als Schüler, dass man da neue Theorien hatte, dass alles sehr wissenschaftlich sein muss und man hat sich eigentlich dann Mühe gegeben, das Abitur so zuzuschneiden, also mit abstrakter Mengenlehre usw. Das war ja damals so ein Politikum und Sprachanalysen und weiß ich was. Dass man es als Vorbereitung der Wissenschaftlichkeit gesehen hat. Das steht sogar in Wikipedia so. Eine wahnsinnige Sache fand ich, da habe ich so minutenlang drauf geguckt, ob das der Ernst ist und da steht drin, auch die Hauptschule bringt den Stoff den Schülern etwas praktischer bei, aber sie vernachlässigt keinesfalls den Aspekt der Wissenschaftlichkeit.
Und a merkt man, wenn sozusagen die Grundlegung des heutigen Gymnasiums aus den 60er/70er Jahren nimmt, dass da sehr viel Wert auf Wissenschaft gelegt wird, das heißt man hat überhaupt nicht die Idee gehabt, die Leute auf einen Beruf vorzubereiten, sondern eigentlich auf das Medizin oder Physikstudium. Und dafür hat man das so irgendwie so hingekriegt, also dass die Leute dann hauptsächlich Germanistik oder Philologie studieren, also Lehrer werden, dann Physik studieren, gibt noch Mediziner und Juristen oder so was. Und da hat man bestimmte Annahmen gehabt, wozu die Leute gut sind. Also deswegen hat man diesen wissenschaftlichen Ansatz gemacht, ich will den gar nicht verteufeln, aber damals hat man sich Gedanken gemacht, was will ich für einen Menschen haben, wozu mache ich das Ganze da im Abitur. Das hat ja eine historische Grundlage gehabt.
Und die war damals sehr, da hatte man so eine Affinität zu abstrakten Wissenschaften. Heute hat man eine ganz andere Lage, die ist völlig geändert und jetzt fängt man an oder man hat völlig vergessen, warum das Abitur ist, so wie es jetzt ist. Und die Annahmen hat man vergessen. Also es ist jetzt lange her, also 50 Jahre her seit den 60er Jahren und die neue Generation übernimmt einfach einen Lehrplan, der aus ganz verschiedenen Vorstellungen entstanden ist und diese Vorstellungen sind einfach weg. Und ich finde, die muss man ab und zu mal ausgraben. Sozusagen unter welchen Annahmen haben wir eigentlich irgendwas beschlossen und stimmen diese Annahmen noch? Antwort ist, nein, stimmen sie heute nicht und deswegen finde ich, müsste man die Diskussion nochmal aufgreifen.
Damals hat man sie geführt, warum kann man sie nicht jetzt führen. Es ist ganz offensichtlich, dass man sie jetzt nochmal führen muss.
Was würden Sie sich denn jetzt wünschen, was so speziell das Universitätssystem oder sagen wir mal das gesamte Bildungssystem für einen Kurs einschlägt? Ist alles supi, geht das so sein Ding?
Ist ein bisschen schwer zu sagen, weil vielleicht so in vielen Dingen ist das überhaupt erst seit wenigen Monaten fast möglich. Also praktisch diese ganze Möglichkeit, bei YouTube was hochzuladen und dann auch normal zu Hause zu sehen, also dass auch jeder Internet hat, also nicht nur so 10% wie früher. Das gibt es noch nicht lange. Dann gibt es auch diese Tabletts gibt es noch nicht so lange. Auch dass die älteren Menschen jetzt anfangen, Emails zu schreiben oder mit ihren Kindern auf WhatsApp wenigstens austauschen, was man einkauft usw. Also praktisch wir leben jetzt in einer Zeit, wo die Revolution sehr sehr schnell voneinander geht und wir neigen vielleicht zu sehr jetzt für heute, also aus der Sicht von heute jetzt irgendwie einen Plan zu machen, was man technisch jetzt in dem Bildungssystem machen muss. Man muss aber auch sehen, dass es sich in den nächsten 5 Jahren nochmal radikal verändert.
Jetzt müsste man vielleicht nicht so einen dezidierten Plan machen, dass man sagt, wir filmen jetzt mal alle Vorlesungen, das müsste man auch machen, aber …
Schaden kann es nicht.
Schaden kann es nicht. Ich habe gerade irgendeine berühmte Rede gesucht von Fineman, die von 74, ja da gibt es noch kein YouTube, Pech und dann liest irgendeiner auf YouTube den Text der Rede vor, da hat man schon gar keine Lust zu. Da ist man heute verwöhnt. Da habe ich irgendwas über volkskundliches haben wollen, da gibt es Bilder, die sind aber so 4x4cm im Internet, die kann man nicht vergrößern, weil jetzt damals man ja gar keine Pixel hatte und so weiter. Und da merkt man schon, wie schnell das so rasend geht. Was man vielleicht machen könnte und das ist mein Traum, dass man erst mal anfängt, das ganze Wissen einfach mal aufzustellen, zu kartografieren, dass man vielleicht so ganz große Wissenspools hätte, meinetwegen für alle Vorlesungen der Welt, für alle Theateraufführungen dieser Welt. Die gibt es alle beim ZDF und bei der ARD und die Juristen sagen, das ist rechtlich nicht statthaft oder so, dass der Rundfunkvertrag oder so verbietet es oder der Staatsvertrag verbietet es, dass wir das freigeben.
Und dann sage ich, Leute wir hätten ja jetzt einfach an alten Fernsehserien, Jim Knopf, Kater Mikesch und so weiter hätten wir soviel Material inzwischen, dass wenn man die Mediathek einfach freigibt, mit allem was es so gibt, dass wir mühelos ein Kind bis 20 Jahre aufziehen können und der sieht nur wertvolle Sachen, muss gar kein Mist des Tages irgendwie sehen, der jetzt gerade neu gemacht wird. Also wir haben ja alles da. Und ich lästere immer, dass Goethe nicht daran gedacht hat, den Faust, dass man den Text liest, also das ist ja das Drehbuch für das Stück und man soll doch vielleicht ins Theater gehen, das konnte man damals nicht, da musste man natürlich irgendwie mangels Theater den Text lesen und interpretieren.
Aber heute könnte ich jetzt 1000 Faustfassungen inzwischen nebeneinander in der Mediathek haben und ich kann dann Antigone von ??? oder Sophokles parallel nebeneinander her gucken. Haben wir immer zwei Drehbücher gelesen und gesagt, was ist der Unterschied dazwischen. Völlig doof. Und ich meine, ich kann jetzt Beispiele geben, wo quasi der Schulunterricht fast sinnlos ist gegenüber dem was das Internet bieten könnte. Weil wir mangels Theaterdramen gelesen haben, was man nicht soll. Wir konnten sie nicht vergleichend anschauen, weil es da nie zwei gleiche im Theater gab und so weiter. Nicht jeder lebt in Berlin usw. Und man kann ja ganz neue, also nicht nur den Stoff sozusagen von heute quasi irgendwie ins Internet bringen, sondern ich predige immer, man kann doch auch so Kompositionsprogramme, also dass man sozusagen eine Klaviertastatur auf dem iPad hat und dann die komponiert, dass man selber komponieren lernt.
Ich kann Baukästen machen, Physikbaukästen, dass ich die ganze Elektrik von einem kleinen Kraftwerk selber baue mit virtuellen Teilchen, so wie Lego baue ich und dann funktioniert das. Und dann könnte ich daraus mehr experimentellen Unterrichtsstil nehmen, dass die Leute sich so richtig austoben können, an echten Aufgaben. Ich kann so viel mehr machen und da müsste man mal nachdenken jetzt über die möglichen Lehrmaterialien der Zukunft und dann auch Startups und da irgendwie ermuntern, das zu machen.
Aber da stoßen wir natürlich gerade bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen auf diese wunderbare...
Schulbuchverlage.
Ja und überhaupt halt diese gesamte Urheberrechtsproblematik.
Ja weiß ich.
Lässt sich das auflösen?
Meine Erfahrung ist, wenn man auch an einem Punkt kommt mit einem Startup, dass es großartig ist, dann ändern sie die Gesetze so, dass es dann erlaubt ist.
Aber was muss sich dann da ändern? Also ich wundere mich zum Beispiel immer so, dass beim Radio nicht schon alle mit Schildern auf der Straße herumlaufen und fordern, die Archive auf Ewigkeiten zu öffnen, weil es eigentlich das beste ist, was denen passieren kann.
Ja das könnte man ja mal machen. Ich meine man kann einfach sagen, ich meine Sie müssen sich jetzt so einen Apparat wie ARD und ZDF vorstellen, praktisch die haben, da kann man einfach sagen, wozu gibt es das. Also dann kann man in den Staatsvertrag rein gucken und dann sagt man, das dient der Bildung des Volkes und so weiter. Und das Fernsehen konnte damals privat nicht betrieben werden, viel zu aufwendig gewesen, da hat der Staat gesagt, wir brauchen aber ein Fernsehen und dann machen wir das vom Staat aus. Und da steht alles drin, wozu das gut ist und dass sie Bildung machen sollen für das Volk. Also da steht ganz sicher nicht drin, dass sie hauptsächlich das Geld für Tatorte ausgeben und da einen Hype draus machen müssen, steht nicht im Staatsvertrag. Und da kann man sagen, das was im Staatsvertrag steht wird – ich kenne ihn jetzt nicht auswendig, aber ich würde mal tippen, das ist alles obsolet – und dann könnte man sagen, warum zahlen wir da 23 oder 25 Euro im Monat Haushaltspauschale, was soll das?
Oder man kann einfach sagen, pass auf, wir machen einen ganz neuen Staatsvertrag, wir sagen, was ist der Bildungsauftrag für die nächste Zeit und der ist irgendwie anders und dann legalisiert man das. Da wundere ich mich, dass da gar kein Wille dahinter ist. Natürlich werden sich alle Fernsehleute und sonst was Zeter und Mordio schreien und da ist irgendwie, da ist gar kein Wille dahinter, irgendwas zu machen. Und die Politik ist immer jetzt immer mehr quantitativ. Also sozusagen sie werfen eine Milliarde auf Bildung oder die Eliteuniversitäten kriegen noch eine Milliarde und da gibt es eine Milliarde oder für Tabletts eine Milliarde. Was wir eigentlich brauchen ist dieses inhaltliche Umgestalten, dass wir da Willen ran bringen. Also man muss jetzt an den Inhalten arbeiten, nicht so sehr an, wer kriegt wie viele Tabletts oder so. Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Und bei diesen Inhalten blocken die Juristen also total. Ich habe mal einen Vortrag gehalten beim Fernsehsender, dann habe die gesagt, pass mal auf, das sind alles schöne Ideen, du hast sogar recht oder wir würden ja auch gerne mitmachen, aber es geht juristisch nicht. Dann sage ich, ja macht dass es irgendwie geht, dann sagen sie, nein das wollen die nicht. Und da müsste man fast irgendwie mal demonstrieren. Also vielleicht wäre eine gute Idee, diese Haushaltsabgabe freiwillig zu machen, also dann wird es irgendwie weggeschaltet, also man darf dann eben das erste oder zweite Programm nicht sehen, das wird dann einfach rausgeschaltet aus dem Kabel. Ich verstehe nicht, warum, das muss doch gehen. Wir haben eine Zeit lang in Waldhilsbach die Europacupspiele auf einem Schweizer Sender 2 gesehen. Also hier in Deutschland werden ja immer nur ein paar übertragen, sonst muss man auf Sky.
Bis letztes Jahr ging das so, dass man im Schweizer Fernsehen die Bayern München Spiele gucken konnte, die haben das genommen.
Weil die dafür bezahlt haben.
Nein, das war da im Free TV. Die haben ja andere im Free TV.
Ja gut, aber es hat ja trotzdem jemand dafür bezahlt, dass es im Free TV sein darf.
Ja und da haben sie jetzt von Kabel ??? haben sie die Kanäle gelöscht. Also praktisch während der Spiele kann man das nicht mehr gucken. Dann kann man natürlich doch irgendwie auch sperren, dass man ARD und ZDF guckt. Also das wird einfach gesperrt und dann braucht man keine Haushaltsabgabe zu zahlen. Das ist jetzt juristisch naiv, ich weiß.
Das bringt uns auch glaube ich nicht wirklich weiter.
Nein, aber dann würde glaube ich, dann wäre der Geist da, aus dieser Sache mal was neues zu machen. Ich muss das ja irgendwie unter Druck setzen.
Ja so oder so die neue Zeit fordert neue Maßnahmen. Ich sage, vielen Dank, Gunter Dück für das Gespräch über ja, ich weiß gar nicht...
Gott und die Welt.
Ich habe im Ganzen Schwierigkeiten, dem einen Titel zu geben, aber ich glaube daran kann man auch ganz gut ablesen, dass so eine gewisse Verstörung auch bei allen Mitdenkern existiert darüber, in welche Richtung uns besonders die Digitalisierung nicht nur, aber auch sagen wir mal die gesteigerte Mobilität und die Beschleunigung der Zeit bringt. Aber jetzt sind wir am Ende angekommen. Ich bedanke mich hier bei allen, die wieder zugeschaltet haben und ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.